An ihrer Eröffnungsmelodie sollt ihr sie erkennen, 22 Uhr und neun Minuten. Schönen guten Abend. Hier ist das Chaosradio Nummer 57. Das erste im neuen Jahrtausend, auch akademisch richtig, im neuen Jahrtausend.
Akademisch?
Akademisch, ich mein...
Religiös betrachtet.
Nee, diese Gymnasiastenscheiße.
Eigentlich findet das neue Jahrtausend ja erst am Erden, Erden 2001.
Das ist religiöse Verbremung.
Religiöse Verbremung, hast du aber auch schon gesagt.
Hä, ich mein, das hat irgendwie mal der... Du weißt schon, diese Vatikan beeinflussten Menschen haben halt irgendwann mal festgestellt, dass sie ja irgendwie nicht in der Lage sind, ein Jahr neu zu definieren, was da eigentlich totaler Quatsch ist.
Deswegen fühlt es sich mit eins an.
Die hatten damals noch keine Rechner, Tim.
Die hatten damals noch keine Nullfallen.
Die hatten einfach noch keine Checker und so. Aber ich mein, die haben halt damals auch geglaubt, die Erde würde sich halt um die Sonne...
Ja, und Gottes Geist schwebte über dem Wasser.
All diese Geschichte, das haben wir ja schon mal irgendwie klargestellt.
Ja, im Studio, guten Abend, Tim.
Guten Abend.
Guten Abend, Mitch.
Hallo.
Guten Abend, Sven. Ja, Tim, Mitch und Sven, Sven, Tim und Mitch, Mitch, Sven und Tim im Studio.
Ja, für die Musik.
Ich hab Sven schon kurz erwähnt. Ich kann auch kurz mal bombastisch hier sagen, was Sven so macht. Oder soll ich das Thema lassen? Ähm, für die Musik heute Abend ist ausschließlich Tim verantwortlich. Na ja, wie na ja. Du weißt schon. Spiel mal was. Worum geht's denn heute?
Ich spiel mal was.
Heute geht's...
Hast du wieder getrunken, Tim?
Finde an der Runde bleiben.
Heute geht es um Open Source Development, d.h. wir diskutieren, was es eigentlich bedeutet, im öffentlichen Raum Software zu entwickeln, wie das funktioniert, wie man das betreiben kann, welche Hilfsmittel es dazu gibt.
Wie man so drauf ist, wenn man das macht. Wie man so drauf kommt. Kleinen Kongressrückblick vorher.
Auch das ist möglich.
Was ist das für Musik jetzt?
Die Musik ist aus?
Die Musik ist aus.
Die Musik ist wirklich aus, die Musik.
Echt, echt.
Wie war das mit Tim seiner Festplatte?
Und da hatte ich irgendwie gerade keine Gelegenheit, groß an meiner Festplatte herumzuschrauben.
Geschirmt?
Stell das Ding mal weg von mir.
Was hattest denn du zu tun, wenn du viel zu tun hattest, sodass du dir nicht mal eine ordentliche Festplatte holen konntest?
Na, was man so macht.
Nase bohren in der Öffentlichkeit, irgendwie distanzieren.
Hast dich distanziert?
Ja, und entschuldigt.
Wofür, wovon?
Für alles Mögliche. Erst mal meine Geburt, das hat schon mehrere Wochen gedauert. Irgendwie haben ja permanent alle Leute was dran zu meckern.
Das heißt, es ist jetzt auch kein Geheimnis mehr, dass ich dich mit dem Schaf damals erwischt.
Nee, das ist jetzt alles auch.
Das ist öffentlich dokumentiert.
Und ich werd auch bei Gelegenheit dem Stern nochmal interviewen.
Schiebfack, komm.
Ja, ansonsten war noch Kongress, glaub ich.
Ja, war witzig. Stimmt. Vor allen Dingen der Monolith war schön. Ja. Und ich hab irgendwie eine Stunde vor diesem Monolithen gestanden und gedacht, ich würde mich jetzt vielleicht auf eine neue Evolutionsstufe begeben können, aber hat irgendwie nicht geklappt. Hat nicht funktioniert? Nee, hat nicht funktioniert. Also ich hab nicht mal gekloppt. Ich war nur einen Tag da.
Ja, du warst nur einen Tag da?
Ich war nur einen Tag da.
Hast du noch was anderes zur Kenntnis genommen?
Ja, was sehr schön war, bei den Hexen konnte man ja Mario Kart spielen. Ich glaube, das war noch vor Neujahr. Auf jeden Fall habe ich mir eine N64 mit Mario Kart gekauft.
Echt?
Ja, und jetzt ist Heugi, spielt jetzt den ganzen Tag Mario Kart. Das habe ich auch noch wahrgenommen. Und dann habe ich wahrgenommen, dass Heise mal wieder gemeldet hat, wie war das? Wer durfte nicht teilnehmen? Mitarbeiter von Startup-Unternehmen. Und das haben sie dann irgendwie missverstanden, aber auch erst zwei Tage später aufgeklärt, die Trottel.
Ja, sie haben es nicht ganz verstanden.
Nee, sie haben es überhaupt nicht verstanden.
Aber sie haben sich am Ende distanziert.
Ja genau, die bleibt noch. Und ein PIX-Set habe ich mir gekauft.
Hab ich auch gekauft. Aber ich kann es nicht irgendwie. Ich habe es nicht mitgekriegt, irgendwie nicht geschafft, so einen Kurs mitzumachen. Ich habe so ein PIX-Set mit lauter Teilen, die alle gleich aussehen.
Du hast ja auch genau dieses Silberne, ne?
Ne, das Gute, das wo 100er waren.
Für 100er, nicht das für 60er, wo man auch noch Schrumpfgummi drauf hat.
Aber es ist alles so.
Aber man hat ja keine Zeit gehabt, einen Kurs zu machen.
Das hat bei mir ganz gut. Also da war die, so eine Mädel, die hieß Ute, die hatte ich vorher noch nie gesehen, und die hat mir beigebracht, wie das geht.
Was denn überhaupt, erklärt doch mal.
Achso, Entschuldigung, wir haben uns kleine Rezisionswerkzeuge gekauft. Sportgeräte. Sportgeräte, genau, Sportgeräte, mit denen man das ein oder andere Schloss aufkriegt. Aber wirken eher das ein, das andere nicht.
Also wenn ich mal den Lockpicker, dann habt ihr euch erstmal mit amtlicher Technologie eingedeckt.
Ja, und wenn ich mehr Geld dabei gehabt hätte, hätte ich auch versucht, so ein elektrisches Ding zu kriegen, weil die sind da rein. Ja, so ähnlich, also steckste rein, dann macht es... und dann ist das Ding auf. Ja, aber es ist irgendwie so...
Das ist mit der Feinfälligkeit nicht hinbekommen.
Nee, das ist für so Leute wie mich...
Oder wenn man halt mal schnell rein ist.
Genau.
Und was mir dann auch noch aufgefallen ist auf dem Kongress ist irgendwie, das war irgendwie unterdimensioniert, also es war fürchterlich voll und hat gestunken. Was hat gestunken? Die ganzen Vortragssäle. Ich hab dermaßen Kopf schnappsen.
Hacker, die duschen sich alle nicht.
Echt duschen Hacker sich nicht?
Also ich hab mir das schon auch vorgestellt.
Das kann man doch mal in Hackerhautusch schreien, nie duschen. Absolut nicht. Das fand ich ein bisschen schade, weil ich hab irgendwie...
Ja, in der Aula kann man auf jeden Fall noch mal vorne die Tür aufpacken. Muss man sich halt drum kümmern.
Also eigentlich kann man überall atmen, außer im Hackcenter. Da kann man einfach nicht atmen. Das war heftig.
Echt, war das letztes Jahr so schlimm?
Na, kein Vergleich zu gestern, zu letztem Jahr.
Da war ich nicht da alleine.
Ja, da war das extrem. Wir haben ja massiv überlaufen worden. Dieses Jahr haben wir das dann mit einer Voranmeldung ein bisschen in etwas brauchbarer Bahn geregelt. Das hat auch ganz gut funktioniert, sodass irgendwie so 600, 700 Rechner wohl da waren. Und letztes Jahr waren es also gut 30% mehr. Und das hat sich dann schon sehr negativ ausgewirkt, sodass der untere Hackcenterbereich zurecht den Namen Puma-Käfig trug.
Das war diesmal nicht ganz wahrgemacht.
Was war denn das eigentlich für eine Taschenkontrolle am Ausgang? War das ernst oder war das einfach so, mal gucken, was da alles mitmachen?
Das war der Test.
Und, haben sie mitgemacht? Das Argument mit den Lernkarten fand ich aber ganz witzig, ehrlich gesagt. Das Argument mit Lernkarten, dass die geklaut werden, fand ich ganz lustig.
Ja, das ist halt die allgemeine Verwirrung, die da irgendwie in der Streckenweise mal erzeugt werden muss.
Ansonsten war es halt eigentlich doch ganz gut, fand ich. Also der Kongress hat sich ganz gut eingestellt hier in Berlin nach drei Jahren. Und da denke ich, wird auch sich irgendwie weiter hier gut einspielen. Und noch ein bisschen mehr Bandbreite entwickeln, so mit den Logpickern zum Beispiel, oder auch Aktivität in der Seabase. So ist es halt schon deutlich jenseits einer reinen Hackerveranstaltung.
Das ist natürlich auf jeden Fall nach wie vor den Schwerpunkt.
Hast du das gerade Jeopardy!
mitbekommen? Nee.
Aber du weißt, was Jeopardy!
Ja, ich glaube, ich sag dir ne Antwort, du hast mir die Frage.
Dieses komische Quiz, wo alles ein bisschen andersrum ist.
Aus das Glasauge von Frank Elst.
Genau, und das war es halt diesmal für Hacker. So mit einer amtlichen Installation, irgendwie so eine Leinwand, wo dann halt auch so das entsprechende Spielfeld von Jeopardy! eingeblendet war. Entsprechend gegrillt, bloß da halt nicht irgendwie Natur oder Promis, was man so normalerweise da findet, sondern halt so dem wie Etizide.
Protokolle 300 bitte.
Genau, Kryptik Modem Strings, die ähnliche Geschichten, da musste man halt auf eine 72 die da steht, irgendwie laut schreien, was ist SH? Und während der AfD-Show halt irgendwie blöd in die Luft guckte und ich wusste bloß, das Thema hat die andere halt laut gejohlt und das war schon riesen Spaß.
Das hab ich leider verpasst. Chaosradio 57, wir reden noch über den letzten Kongress. Was ich auch total klasse fand im Art and Beauty Center, da war ein Typ, der hat, naja, so ein Quasi-Saxophon gespielt. Also das sah aus wie ein halbes Saxophon, ohne Tröte unten dran und ohne richtiges Mundstück und da hingen Kabel dran. Da kamen so ähnliche Töne wie aus dem Saxophon raus, aber eben doch nicht wirklich.
Das kann so ein MIDI-Controller gewesen sein.
MIDI-Eingabegerät.
Hab ich ja noch nie in meinem Leben vorher gesehen. Das war super geil.
Du hast auch Drums anschließen und alles und alles geht direkt in Cubase rein oder in irgendein schönes Musikprogramm.
Also die haben da ganz fleißig experimentiert mit allerlei möglichen Geräten und auch versucht irgendwie die einzelnen Soundprojekte, die da waren, über ein gemeinsames Mischpult zusammenzutragen. Da ist auch irgendwie interessante Musik mal rausgekommen, die wir demnächst noch auf den Server stellen. Das ist jetzt so gerade alles mal so zusammengetragen worden und zusammengeschnitten worden. So wie übrigens auch die ganze Kongressdokumentation sozusagen noch ihre Veröffentlichungen hart. Das ist aber alles so, naja, ich will jetzt nicht real soon now sagen, aber wir kommen da vorwärts.
Wann kommst du aus dem Urlaub zurück?
Ja, bis dahin sollte das eigentlich alles laufen. Wir haben die ganze Veranstaltung diesmal digital getapet, also die ganzen Videostreams sozusagen gleich vor Ort digital produziert. Nebenbei noch ein analogisches Backup mitlaufen lassen. Klar, das hat dann auch noch die eine oder andere Sache gerettet, wo die Maschinen nicht ganz so zuverlässig liefen, sodass wir die Hoffnung haben, dass wir demnächst den kompletten Kongress als DivX online bringen können. Ein Teil ist auch schon konvertiert, aber wie das nun mal so ist, man muss halt erst mal diese 6 Gigabyte Dateien, muss man irgendwie erst mal Prozess bekommen und das stellt dann doch an die Betriebssysteme heute schon so einige Anforderungen, die sie nicht unbedingt immer so ohne Weiteres erfüllen oder eben auch die Programme so.
Das ist das 32-Bit-Problem, nicht?
Wann schlägt das richtig zu? 2029 oder so?
Das 32-Bit-Problem, das schlägt jetzt schon.
Ja, nee, ich meine, da gab es doch irgendwie so ein magisches Datum noch.
Ja, da gibt es irgendwie der Tag, wo das Unix-System-Date halt irgendwie voll ist, weil auch das mit 32-Bit die Sekunden seit dem 1.1.1970 zählt und das ist dann irgendwie, wann war das? Da ist dann halt irgendwie Ende. Das wird auch immer ganz spaßig so. Das wird auch schon vorher sicherlich schon die ein oder andere Probleme bringen.
Also ist dann Ende, Ende oder ist dann so Ende wie beim Millennium Bug, wo sich einfach nur ziemlich viele Leute drum und drüben...
Also das ist, ich meine, das ist ein bisschen schwer einzuschätzen, was in den nächsten 30 Jahren irgendwie im Bereich Unix alles so passiert. Ich denke, die Zeitspanne reicht theoretisch schon aus, um sich vorher darüber Gedanken zu machen. Aber wie das so ist...
Bis dahin. Aber die anderen 64-Bit-Systeme zählen noch Millionen weiter.
Echt kann man an die Xbox einen Monitor anschließen? Ich weiß nicht.
Ja, aber 64-Bit ist jetzt schon bitter nötig. Das merkt man jetzt schon, wenn man auf Dateien zugreift. Dateigrößen über 4 GB konnte man sich ja bis vor Kurzem auch nicht so richtig vorstellen. Aber jetzt, wo es irgendwie Digital-Video gibt, sieht das natürlich ganz anders aus. Und da ist natürlich irgendwie so der Zugriff auf so eine Datei, stößt ja schon an solche Grenzen.
Das war's.
Am Dienstag in den Radio Fritz in Hamburg.
22.31.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Mit dem Wetter nachts gebietweise, gebietsweise Nebel örtlich glätte bei Temperaturen um die Null Grad am Tag, dann nass kalt, Höchstwerte zwischen zwei und vier Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Falk Zilke.
Die zuständigen Landesminister für Verbraucherschutz haben sich auf eine gemeinsame Linie bei der Rinderkrankheit BSE verständigt. Nach einer Sitzung in Bremen forderten die Minister die Bundesregierung auf, die BSE-Forschung zu verstärken und die Schnelltests auf alle Schnachttiere auszuweiten. Zudem sollten Medikamente und Antibiotika in der Tierzucht verboten werden. Im Zuge der Bundeswehrreform sollen 59 Standorte geschlossen werden. Nach den Vorstellungen von Verteidigungsminister Scharping bleiben die Länder Berlin und Brandenburg von Schließungen zwar verschont, allerdings sollen die Stützpunkte in Brück und Strausberg und Cottbus verkleinert werden. Nach dem schweren Erdbeben im Westen Indiens besteht kaum noch Hoffnung für die rund 100.000 Vermissten. Die Retter konnten heute nur noch wenige Überlebende aus den Trümmern befreien. Die Medien sprachen von bis zu 35.000 Toten. In Berlin sollen alle öffentlichen Schwimmbäder auf einen möglichen Befall durch legionellen Bakterien untersucht werden. Das kündigte die Gesundheitsverwaltung an. Die Behörde reagierte damit auf die Entdeckung der Krankheitserreger, die bereits zur Schließung von drei Schwimmhallen geführt haben. Eine Meldung vom Verkehr, Art 10 östlicher Berliner Ring, Dreieck Schwanebeck Richtung Dreieck Spreeau zwischen Rödersdorf und Erkne ist die rechte Spur wegen einer Baustelle bis morgen Abend gesperrt.
Danke Falk, 22.33 Uhr.
Große Ereignisse werfen ihren Schatten voraus. Freitag, 9. Februar, 21 Uhr, Messehallen Frankfurt oder Vollton, Nies, West Bank.
Guten Abend, hier ist das Chaosradio Nr. 57 auf Fritz. Und wir wollten jetzt endlich mal zum eigentlichen Thema der Sendung kommen, nämlich Open Source Development. Ich überlasse einfach mal das Wort einem der drei Herren, die sich damit besser auskennen als ich, nämlich Mitch, Sen oder Tim. Tja, wer fühlt sich jetzt angesprochen?
Einen der drei Herren über das Wort. Also es geht um Open Source Development. Wir hatten ja beim letzten Mal, in der letzten Sendung, der 56er Sendung schon das Thema Intellectual Property und die ganze K-Sensor. Wir hatten es da schon leicht angesprochen. Tja, und bei Open Source geht es halt im Allgemeinen um freie Software. Das übliche, frei im Sinne von Rede, nicht frei im Sinne von Bier. Und ja, das zusammen mit anderen im Netz zu entwickeln und jede Menge Spaß zu haben.
Open Source Development ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht schon ein Phänomen, was irgendwie auch nicht wirklich neu ist, aber was natürlich mit der Aktualität des Internets, Internet überall und mehr Leuten, die sich daran beteiligen, natürlich jetzt irgendwie zunehmende Bedeutung bekommt. Nicht zuletzt deshalb, weil ja auch alle großen Companies auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise auch schon auf den Open Source Zug mit aufgesprungen sind, eigentlich mit der Ausnahme von Microsoft. Wobei ich gar nicht abschließen möchte, dass sie das nicht auch noch mal tun.
So Ars Electronica, diese herrliche Falschmeldung gab. Linux hätte den Preis nur gekriegt, weil Microsoft Druck auf die Juroren ausgeübt hätte, weil nämlich Microsoft mit Dell zusammen an einer eigenen Linux-Distribution arbeitet. Das war die geilste Ente, die ich in meinem Lesen gehört habe. Die war super. Das haben die Kollegen von übermorgen.com aus Österreich gemacht, wo sie auch Vote-Auction gemacht haben. Das fand ich richtig klasse. Abends haben sie diese Mail verschickt an 250 Leute, die keine Journalisten sind, in der Hoffnung, dass eben irgendeiner von den Journalisten informiert. Und am anderen Morgen auf der PK wussten alle Journalisten davon, nur die Juroren nicht. Und haben dann natürlich dementiert. Und damit war das Ding gegessen. Da haben wir noch nie was von gehört. Okay, ist es wahr.
Das muss wahr sein.
Sehr schön gewesen.
Haben sie sich auch distanziert? Entschuldigt?
Ich glaube nicht. Wäre jetzt Microsoft oder Dell?
Nein, die Juroren.
Microsoft entschuldigt sich nie.
Obwohl, die hätten echt eine Menge Grund dazu.
Die Juroren oder Microsoft?
Die sind nicht mal in der Lage, in einem Nameserver zu betreiben. Das ist reine Dummheit, richtig.
Hast du das mitgekriegt?
Ja, das war sehr lustig.
Also, da haben sie sich auch, ich meine, da konnte man mich aber so richtig amtlich mit dem Finger auszeigen, weil...
Ja, obwohl ich ja irgendwo auch gelesen hab, dass deren wesentlichsten Server alle Unix-Server sind.
Ach, die können sicherlich, Microsoft glaub ich, auch für alle Bereiche durchaus kompetentes Human Resource Menschen Kapital irgendwie am Start, aber sie haben halt einfach einen exlataunten Fehler gemacht, indem sie einfach ihre ganzen sekundären Nameserver, also die, die sozusagen ins Boot springen, wenn die Primären ausfallen, alle in das gleiche Netz gepackt und dann diese ganzen DOS-Attacken, die halt da gefahren wurden, gegen ihre Router gingen und nicht gegen ihre Web-Server, wie das sonst so der Fall ist. Das ist ja auch irgendwie langsam langweilig.
Jetzt schnappt man sich irgendwie...
Jetzt machen wir die Router tot. Jetzt nimmt man sich die Cisco's vor. Die ganze Welt benutzt ja irgendwie auch dasselbe mehr oder minder. Die iOS-Sourcen sind auch irgendwie mehr oder minder im Netz verfügbar. iOS ist das Betriebssystem, was auf Cisco-Geräten läuft. Die haben halt ein eigenes Realtime-Routing-Betriebssystem. Das nennt sich iOS, also Input-Output.
Aber es ist nicht Open Source, die Sourcen sind nur so...
Es ist nicht offiziell Open Source.
Es ist Source Open quasi.
Das ist halt irgendwie bekannt oder...
Beziehungsweise man benötigt ja auch den Source Code nicht unbedingt, um Schwachstellen herauszufinden. Da reichen halt so ein paar Attacken. Das kann ja auch jeder mit seiner eigenen Cisco ausprobieren und da irgendwie alle anderen dasselbe fahren. Geht das halt da immer im Prinzip genau das gleiche Problem der Mono-Kultur irgendwie so, nicht? Also man kauft halt irgendwie Cisco heutzutage. Klar, es gibt auch noch andere Router-Hersteller, die gute Produkte machen, aber es ist auf jeden Fall am verbreitetsten.
Hat Sie mensch das nicht auch mal versucht? Router zu bauen? Oder machen die das noch?
Ich hab noch ein paar Firmen, die das machen, aber...
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist nicht so deren Business.
Auf jeden Fall wurde deren Netz plattgemacht, und dadurch, dass das Netz als solches nicht mehr erreichbar war, waren natürlich auch automatisch alle DNS-Server da drin nicht erreichbar, und deswegen war die Domain auf einmal nicht mehr bekannt.
Jetzt haben Sie sich auch sagen, dass ich die schöne Gerüche gehört hab, dass sie alle ihre Nameserver in einem Gebäude haben, und sie sind alle über ein Router angebunden. Wenn das wirklich stimmt, dann sind sie also echt so blöd, wie ich das gesagt hab.
Das heißt, wenn man es mit DOS-Attacken nicht plattkriegt, schalt man einfach den Strom ab.
Genau.
Das schmeckt wahrscheinlich alle in einer Sektose.
Stromproblemen haben sie ja auch gerade in der Gegend.
Ja, schade. Wobei ich nicht genau weiß, ob das auch Seattle betrifft.
Seattle ist nicht ganz im Silicon Valley, oder?
Nee, es ist nicht wirklich Kalifornien.
Nee, bisschen ab.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Open Source hätte in dem Fall jetzt auch nicht weitergeholfen. Open Source bringt einem irgendwie noch lange nicht Netzwerkmanagement bei. Aber das ist halt ein anderes Problem. Ja, gut, Open Software Entwicklung. Das ist halt das, was irgendwie Microsoft nicht macht. Aber es machen halt andere Firmen. In diesem ganzen Linux-Hype der letzten Jahre haben halt viele große Firmen, vor allem muss man da halt IBM nennen, sind da kräftig auf diesen Zug mit aufgesprungen. Das heißt, man kriegt eigentlich von jedem größeren PC-Hersteller heutzutage den Rechner auch in irgendeiner Form mit einer Linux-Default-Konfiguration. Das heißt, die bemühen sich sozusagen auch, dass eben für die Hardware, die sie so einsetzen, für ihre Mainboards, das Linux eben darauf läuft. Das ist auch alles gut so. Dadurch ist einfach auch die Hardware besser dokumentiert. Und IBM ist auch dazu übergegangen, selber die Software, die sie entwickeln, insbesondere im Java-Bereich, eben auch öffentlich verfügbar zu machen, weil sie eben verstanden haben, welche Vorteile das hat. Das ist einerseits, also aus deren Sicht geht es natürlich vor allem darum, die haben halt einfach Angst, dass ihre Software keiner mehr benutzt, wenn alle Leute sich auf Open Source-Software stürzen. Das ist auch durchaus berechtigt so. Also viele Firmen haben sich eigentlich in den letzten Jahren ihre eigenen Marktchancen vollständig vergeigt, weil sie einfach immer auf ihrem Source-Code rumgesessen haben. Das war natürlich schön doof. Aber Open Source Development, also richtig ein verteiltes entwickeln, das ist natürlich dann auch schon mal eine ganz andere Geschichte. Also einfach nur seinen Source-Code verfügbar machen, das ist schon mal ganz gut. Aber eben auch wirklich mit einer Community, die vorher so nicht festgelegt wurde, daran zu arbeiten, das ist eben dann ein anderer Schritt.
Legt die sich denn im Laufe des Arbeitens fest oder macht man das eher vorher?
Das ist einfach, das passiert einfach. Die Leute, die sich für dasselbe interessieren, die sich für die gleiche Art von Programmen interessieren, stoßen auf die Programme oder fangen an, die Programme zu hacken. Dann kommen andere, die das geil finden und machen mit und schicken Patches. Also es kommt glaube ich selten vor, dass sich 10 Leute treffen und sagen, wir machen jetzt ein Open Source Projekt irgendwie.
Wir gründen eine Open Source-Komponie.
Genau, irgendwelche Freaks fangen an und andere finden das cool, weil es ins Netz gestellt wurde. Und gucken sich den Code gemeinsam an und viele Augen können mehr fixen als nur zwei Augen.
Was ich ja schön finde, ist, es gibt, also ich meine die meisten benutzen ja nun Windows, es gibt ja auch schon einiges Gutes für Windows. Das finde ich irgendwie ganz angenehm. Also dann kann man wenigstens mit ethisch unbedenklicher Software auf diesem ethisch bedenklichen Betriebssystem arbeiten. Das gefällt mir ganz gut.
Du meinst freies Software jetzt für Windows?
Einen schönen Mailer habe ich gefunden. Phoenix heißt der, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr ihn dann kennt. Der ist wirklich ganz, ganz toll. Also unter 1 MB groß und kann Multiple Accounts und sowas. Dafür braucht Outlook Express ein bisschen MB.
Ja, das ist ganz interessant.
Es schwappt irgendwie auch Windows rüber, aber gleichzeitig kommen halt auch unheimlich viele Windows-User und lassen Windows einfach von der Platte verschwinden und fangen an komplett mit freies Software zu arbeiten. Richtig ganz mit dem ganzen Betriebssystem.
Bestimmt. Also Linux zieht ganz offensichtlich viele Leute ab, die irgendwie vorher nur Windows gemacht haben. Das hat jetzt mittlerweile genug Reiz.
Es funktioniert ja auch in einer angemessenen Weise, sag ich mal, selbst für den dummen User.
Man kann es als User echt benutzen.
Genau. Also wenn man nicht wirklich vollständig jetzt irgendwie...
Selbst dann, also hast du mal eine Suze, was hab ich da? Ist das 7.0 oder 7.1? Wie sich das installiert, ist echt schon lächerlich gut. Also das ist wirklich, es ist eigentlich schöner als Windows. Der findet wirklich auch noch sämtliche Hardware, die da so rum ist, also eine eigene Hardware Detection. Und das finde ich irgendwie ganz gut. Also es ist somit eben auch für blöde.
Ja, aber es ist halt interessant, wie es überhaupt möglich ist, dass so ein Betriebssystem überhaupt genug Unterstützung bekommt von irgendwie freien und bezahlten Entwicklern, damit es eben diese Stabilität erreicht. Und das heißt, es gibt ein großes Interesse daran, weil die Leute auch gesehen haben, dass es für ihr eigenes Lernen und das ist ja das, was die meisten Leute treibt, einfach viel, viel besser ist, mit anderen Leuten zusammen an einer Software zu arbeiten. Oder zumindest in vielen Fällen mindestens reizvoll ist das zu tun, um das mal ein bisschen einzuschränken, als nur jetzt irgendwie seinen eigenen Code zu hacken und darauf rumzusetzen. Bringt auch irgendwie interessante soziale Interaktionen mit ins Boot. Ich hab jetzt gerade irgendwie eine E-Mail bekommen von irgendjemand, der meinte, du hast doch mal dieses Programm geschrieben sowieso. Und ich dachte nach und es ist irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ich glaube es ist zehn Jahre her.
Was war es für eins?
Ganz publiges Tool, was einem irgendwie unter Unix eine Funktionalität gibt, die damals nicht verbreitet war, die heute verbreitet ist, so eine Art Sudo. Also man kann eben mal schnell für ein Kommando das mit anderen Rechten ausführen. Idealerweise mit Administratorrechten. Das war halt häufiger Brauch, so muss man sich nicht als Administrator einloggen, sondern man macht eben genau diesen einen Schritt mit anderen Rechten. Und das will man halt irgendwie bequem auf der Kommandozeile haben, das gab es halt damals nicht bequem, und dann hab ich mir das halt mal bequem gehackt. Und ich hab keine Ahnung, also ich hab es nicht wirklich irgendwie veröffentlicht, denn dieser Thought Code ist irgendwie so rumgewandert. Irgendwann mal von meiner Platte hat er sich so weggehoben, wahrscheinlich in irgendeinen News Group oder irgendein Server gefallen.
Hast du mal in den Sudokod geschaut? Hast du mal in den Sudokod geschaut? Vielleicht ist das ja so. Was ist das?
Naja, ich meinte ja zu ihm irgendwie, wozu brauchst du denn bitte noch dieses alte Tool? So irgendwie, es gibt doch irgendwie Sudo und so. Und er meinte, naja, Sudo ist ja ganz nett, aber es kann halt ein paar Sachen nicht, die irgendwie jetzt mit deinem Tool gerade ganz besonders elegant gingen. Das ist eben genau der Reiz irgendwie, wie man auf Open Source Software irgendwie stößt. Man stellt halt fest, A, das ist jetzt mal genau das richtige Tool für diesen einen kleinen Zweck. Und das ist das, was mich gerade beschäftigt. Und die Leute fragen jetzt nach dem vollständigen Source Code, damit er selber Änderungen dranmacht. Ich hab jetzt das Problem, dass das Programm noch auf irgendeinem alten KIK24-Tape, so uralt Hardware, wo ich jetzt erstmal einen Bandlauf verfinden muss, was funktioniert das.
Du hast gerade ein Radio, mach einen Aufruf.
Ja, ich brauch unbedingt in Berlin jemand, der einen KIK24-Streamer am Laufen hat, wo ich einfach mal meinen Tape reinschieben kann, um einen Tafel runterzuholen. Falls da irgendwie einer Lust hat, soll er mal an chaos.orb.de eine Mail schicken.
chaosradio.fritz.de oder chaosradio.fritz.de, ah, hat sich geändert.
Oder mail.chaosradio.ccc.de, denkt euch was aus.
Das wär auf jeden Fall cool.
Für alle anderen geben wir gleich noch unsere einzelnen privaten E-Mail-Adressen in den US. Auf Fritz, das Chaosradio 57, Open Source Development ist unser Thema und wir haben uns gerade überlegt, machen wir doch mal noch eine kleine Begriffsdefinition, Open Source Free Software, was es da alles gibt, Tim. Ja Tim, du hast damit angefangen. Ich wollte das ja alles eh nicht.
Ja, du hast das alles nicht verstanden und wir erklären es dir jetzt.
Genau, ich hab's alles nicht verstanden. Ich hab Stormen hinter mir.
Also ich mein, die Frage, die du gestellt hast, ist toll.
Du hast den ganzen Tag mit ihm ausgehalten, das war heftig, er hat für 80 mal gefressen und gesoffen, der Drecksack. Und danach hat er noch einen Kellner angepöbelt im... Nee, gar nicht angepöbelt, das war andersrum. Der war irgendwie sehr gut drauf und wir saßen im 12er Postel am Saviniplatz. Und der Kellner war super unfreundlich und dann hat er ihm irgendwie noch das Essen geschenkt zu dem Rest. Woraufhin der Kellner noch unfreundlich am Morgen, das war wirklich sehr lustig.
Aber er hat nicht gesungen.
Nein, gesungen hat er nicht.
Aber er hat fast eine dreiviertel Stunde einem ganz schlechten Straßenmusiker auf der Museumsinsel zugeguckt und rumgetanzt und Passanten angeschnautzt, die mögen doch bitte mit dem Rauchen aufhören, weil das echt tödlich ist. Waren wir jetzt bei der Begriffsbestimmung?
Ja, also Storyman muss man auch nochmal bestimmen. Das gehört da auch ganz wichtig mit rein. Also, du hast Begriffsbestimmung. Du hast gefragt, was zieht einen eigentlich dazu, Open Source Entwicklung zu machen.
Ja, was ich mir denke ist, also ich sitze zu Hause, programmiere irgendwie ein ganz tolles Ding, ein ganz tolles Tool, ein Programm und denke mir, hey, das ist so cool, das will eh jeder haben. Das verklappe ich jetzt, das verticke ich jetzt. Weil im Zweifelsfall, es programmieren ja auch meinen Beruf und ich muss davon leben oder will davon leben und zwar möglichst gut, so wie es eben der Geist der Zeit hergibt. Also was reizt euch daran, genau das nicht zu haben? Ja, Mitch. Was reizt euch daran?
Tja, also als ich damit angefangen habe, da hab ich überhaupt nicht dran gedacht, mit Geld zu verdienen, weil es die älteste Studentenzeit war und behütet Geld von Eltern und so weiter. Und irgendwie hab ich mir auch nie darüber Sorgen gemacht, ob ich jetzt unbedingt mit dem Programmieren viel Geld verdienen kann, weil ich wusste, dass ich gut programmieren kann und da wird man schöner einen Job kriegen. Das ist nicht irgendwie eine Überlegung gewesen, ob ich jetzt meine ganze, viele wertvolle Zeit in das Stecken solle.
Also das heißt, der normale Softwareentwickler überlegt sich gar nicht vorher, dass er mit dem entwickeln von Software und dem Verkaufen von Programmen seinen Lebensunterhalt verdient, oder doch?
Es gibt halt die Leute, die das einfach machen als Beruf, Leute, denen es einfach Spaß macht. Es ist wirklich Spaß, was zu hacken, was dann hinterher funktioniert, spielt dran rum, es wird besser und besser und besser.
Ja, aber was ist, wenn ich jetzt, ich will mit Computern mein Geld verdienen und ich möchte gern mitprogrammieren, mein Geld verdienen, dann bin ich ja bescheuert, wenn ich Open Source Sachen mache.
Das muss ja noch nicht mal sein. Es gibt genug Firmen, die auch gut mit Open Source Softwareherstellungen leben. Das ist zwar noch ein recht neues Modell, aber es gibt schon ein paar Firmen, die wirklich groß geworden sind damit. Das geht auch, aber das ist eigentlich nicht das, was so den Entwicklern Open Source Spaß macht. Da denkt man vielleicht irgendwann mal hin, wenn ich da lang dran rumhacke, vielleicht stellen sie mich aber Red Hat ein.
Na gut, aber ich denke, es geht hier in allererster Linie überhaupt nicht um Geld. Das ist gar nicht der Punkt. Die Leute, die sich eigentlich in diesem sozialen Raum bewegen, das sind E-Enthusiasten. Das sind Leute, die irgendwie mit ihrem Rechner rumspielen, wie die Kids mit dem Tamagotchi, die einfach irgendwie hegen und pflegen und irgendwie auch das kleinste Bit einfach mal so sein muss, wie sie sich das vorstellen. Das heißt, sie haben einen hochgradigen Drang, ein System zu haben, was einfach ihren Bedürfnissen und ihren Anforderungen und Träumen und Wünschen entspricht. Und umso mehr man eben eingreifen kann in dieses System, umso besser ist das. Gut, viele Benutzer freuen sich schon, wenn sie irgendwie ein Theme runterladen können und dann sind die Fenster halt nicht mehr blau, sondern irgendwie, was weiß ich, schwarz-weiß gefleckt. So irgendwie BSE-Theme und dann ist es prima und dann ist der Rechner irgendwie für ihre Benutzungsbedürfnisse angepasst. Aber für den Programmierer ist das natürlich irgendwie, spielt sich das auf einer ganz anderen Ebene ab. Wenn man als Programmierer auch ein Programm anschaut und das Programm verhält sich irgendwie komisch, dann rauschen einem sofort Algorithmen durch den Kopf, weil man einfach genau weiß, was sie da jetzt gerade scheiße machen. NetScape, wenn man von NetScape irgendwie eine halbe Stunde sitzt, dann kriegt man wirklich einen Krampf irgendwann, weil man sich denkt so, ah, ah, ah.
Werd doch mal konkret, was ist das? Wo ich dann von meinem NetScape sitze, wo kriegst du einen Krampf, den ich nicht kriege?
Ja, zum Beispiel, wenn man irgendwie re-sized man das Fenster und dann muss er, um das irgendwie neu umzubrechen, muss er im Prinzip die Source-Datei noch mal komplett aus seinem Cash laden und rendert sie neu und dann gehen die Eingaben aus den Formularen weg und irgendwie Stats werden irgendwie repostet oder auch nicht repostet und Verbindungen sind weg und es ist alles total braun und langsam und wenn man das irgendwie alles selektiert und macht Cut und Paste, dann sind da New Lines irgendwie in dem Leastext und tausend Sachen, die gerade für den Programmierer spielen, spielt sich das auf einer sehr technischen Ebene ab, weil man riecht geradezu, was sie da verbrochen haben. Da möchte man einfach sofort sein Editor of Choice starten und einfach rein in den Code und das Elend aus dem eigenen Computer irgendwie heraus operieren. Und das geht einfach nur, wenn der Source Code da ist. Und deswegen zieht es die Leute dazu, Open Source Software zu benutzen und zwar auch bevorzugt zu benutzen, selbst wenn ein kommerzielles Tool dieses und jenes spells and whistles Feature hat. Gerade im Browserbereich ist das ja ganz typisch. Die ganzen hochglanzpolierten kommerziellen Browser, die haben halt tolle Sachen. Aber die können halt an einer Stelle nicht überzeugen, wo es einfach eben ums Mitspracherecht des Benutzers geht. Weil irgendwie bei Mozilla ist es, also Netscape hat ja irgendwann seinen Source Code veröffentlicht und da ist ein Mozilla Projekt daraus gemacht, so wie Netscape auch früher im Codenamen hieß. Und der Mozilla Code ist halt verfügbar unter einer speziellen Netscape Lizenz, die recht offen ist. Und deswegen kann man sich eben den Code nehmen und auch in seine eigenen Programme einbauen. Also jetzt ist ja gerade Netscape 6 rausgekommen, beziehungsweise parallel halt Mozilla 06, beziehungsweise 07 angelangt mittlerweile. Also da gibt es schon sozusagen auch ein moderneres Release, was es so von Netscape so nicht gibt, von mehr oder minder dem gleichen Source Code. Und es gibt auch viele kleine Projekte, die jetzt einfach die Perlen aus dem Mozilla Code sich rauspicken, wie zum Beispiel den neuen HTML Renderer, dieser Gecko, der ist halt recht performant und irgendwie standardskonform.
Ich fand den so extrem performant.
Ja, das ist halt mal, da haben sie halt jetzt auch wirklich mal ein paar Jahre irgendwie mal frisch programmiert und irgendwie wussten auch in etwa, was die Zukunft ihnen bringt mit XML, dass sie sich da sowieso...
Das Problem ist, dass während der performt, raucht irgendwas anderes ab in dem Ding.
Das war ein Problem.
Der Rest von Netscape 7 ist einfach gigantisch.
Das ist heftig. Das ist heftig laut.
Und das ist bei Mozilla auch nicht anders. Das ist fast dasselbe Tool. Und die haben eine unglaubliche Menge an Source-Gut da zusammengehackt. Weil hier nicht so eine Source rausgekommen ist.
Also warum ist das so umfangreich? Weil wenn ich mir die Oberen angucke, das kann praktisch dasselbe.
Ja, die sind auf den Markt aufgetreten und haben ja ihren Browser weitgehend kostenfrei irgendwie vertrieben. Nur wenn jetzt irgendwie Service Provider auf eine CD packen wollten, mussten sie was abtun. Das war so ein bisschen Revenue, aber nicht wirklich. Und sie haben vor allem die Standards gesetzt. Und sie hatten ja irgendwie den Traum... Also letzten Endes haben sie Geld verdient nur mit ihren Serverprodukten. Das ist auch jetzt noch so. Netscape Server. Und dann haben sie halt auch gleich im Zuge mit diesem Java-Hype und JavaScript gleich von komplett neuen Entwicklungsumgebungen, die halt netzbasiert sind mit Java und irgendwie nur noch Objekte, Netz und alles ganz verklärt. Nur dass ihre Software einfach niemals wirklich so richtig gut funktioniert hat, sodass man nicht davon sprechen kann, dass jetzt irgendwie diese Netscape-Internet-Plattformen, die sie da haben, eine wirkliche Alternative ist. Und das war sich ja von der Hinsicht auch Java sozusagen da eigentlich als der Gewinner herausstellt.
Was mich zum Beispiel gerade bei Netscape so völlig wahnsinnig macht, ist der Umfang dieses Programms. Also das ist dermaßen groß. Ich weiß nicht, es kommt glaube ich mittlerweile über 20 MB auf meiner Platte. Was nicht so schlimm ist, weil meine Platte groß genug ist, aber wenn ich mir Opera runter lade, dann macht das keine 7 MB aus.
Das ist noch zu viel.
Es gibt ein paar interessante Open Source-Projekte, die jetzt kleine Browser machen auf der Technologie von Mozilla, aber ohne den ganzen Krandomum, ohne E-Mail, ohne News.
Einfach nur ein Browser, der schnell da ist und geht.
Und der heißt dann Mosaik?
Der heißt dann Galleon zum Beispiel.
Galleon mit einzelnen Browsern, bzw. es werden auch die einzelnen Komponenten, wie zum Beispiel das Gecko genommen und eben in ganz andere Subsysteme eingebaut, wie zum Beispiel bei Nautilus, das ist so ein Projekt für Linux. GNU war auch noch mal darauf zu sprechen gekommen heute, wo man sozusagen ein amtliches User interface mit Filebrowser und so weiter geboten bekommt, wo man möglichst gleichförmig mit allen möglichen Daten navigieren kann. Und da gehört natürlich auch HTML dazu. Also wird einfach diese eine Komponente, Gecko, einfach herausgenommen aus dem Mozilla Projekt und in einem ganz anderen Kontext verwendet. Und so muss es auch sein. Und da zeigt sich eben, dass Open Source diese ganze Szene, die beflügeln sich alle gegenseitig. Das ist ein permanentes Befruchten sozusagen. So ein bisschen wie die Bienen fliegen sie da über die Wiese und jeder legt halt irgendwie so seinen Nektar ab. Und da gibt es dann dieses schöne Bild von dem Cooking Pot Market. Das ist so dieser Cocktopfmarkt. Jeder hat, der eine hat Gemüse, der andere hat Kartoffeln, der andere hat Wasser. Und so kann halt jeder irgendwie so ein bisschen Wasser schlürfen oder so ein bisschen an seiner Kartoffeln nagen. Aber sie können das halt auch alles in einen Topf schmeißen.
Dann kriegen sie alle Borsch.
Genau.
So.
Und genauso funktioniert das. Und dadurch entsteht eine unglaubliche Dynamik, die unter anderem zu Linux, aber eben auch zu ganz vielen anderen großen Sachen und mittlerweile eben auch vollwertigen Anwendungen geführt hat.
Ja und es ist exakt 23 Uhr und ich hab einfach den Ausfall von Tims Festplätze dazu benutzt, dieses sogenannte Jingle zu spielen. Sie ist immer noch kaputt. Das Chaosradio 57 ist hier. Wir reden über Open Source, Open Source Development, wollten eigentlich nur über GIMP reden, machen wir auch noch, aber vorher reden wir mit Marc. Hallo Marc.
Guten Abend, hi.
Du bist Open Source Developer, lese ich auf meinem Display. Mehr lese ich allerdings nicht, den Rest musst du erzählen.
Ja, also ich bastle an meiner eigenen Software, hab profilizierte auf meiner Website. Und krieg dann ab und zu mal wirklich ein paar Comments zu dem Code, wo vereinnahmt werden muss, was optimiert werden muss und es ist wirklich praktisch.
Was für Software?
Hauptsächlich Entwicklung von Bilddaten aus mathematischen Formeln.
Das passt doch zum Thema.
Hey Jungs, mach dir dann alleine weiter, ich geh so nach Hause.
Ich hab mir mit meinem Vater aus einer alten Zitane ein paar Spektakelquartot für Delfi rausgezogen und raus ein Programm geschrieben. Er hat mir mathematischen Kram eingebläut und ich hab halt eh das Programm zu Dummy-Schnitten und so weiter irgendwann auf den Website gestellt. Da kamen dann so schnell Comments, was an den Dingen, an welchen Stellen das abgestößt ist, wann der Stack überlaufen ist und so weiter. Das ist immer das praktische bei Open Source. Und man nachdem ja wirklich am Ende kommt, dass fertig ist, kann ich das als Gemeinschaftsproduktion in den Verkauf schicken. Wenn die Leute wissen, was das ist, dass das Produkt gut ist, dass der Ressourcekurs von vielen Leuten optimiert worden ist, werden sie das sicherer kaufen als ich. Unbekannte Programme.
Moment, du developst das unter Open Source und danach machst du die Lizenz zu?
Nein.
Du verklobst das dann nicht proprietär?
Nein, nein, ich mach das anders. Ich hab ein Team von Leuten, mit denen ich Open Source mit mir als Arbeiter netteile. Wenn wir mit denen arbeiten, ist das Ding noch Open Source. Also man kann sich das runterladen. Sobald dieses Projekt abgeschlossen ist, da ist wirklich nur die Zusammenarbeit mit dabei.
Und das machen die Leute mit, ja.
Was machst du dann mit?
Das ist mit der letzten Version, die im Netz lag. Die kannst du doch nicht wegregen.
Die Software ist aber nach wie vor frei, wenn du es verkaust.
Ja, die Eigenversionen, die mittlere Version, weil ich hau ich dann im Netz als Freeware. Als Freeware, wo du bemerkst, heißt, die können Geld zahlen. Ich verlange es nicht unbedingt. Aber wir.
Aber das ist doch nicht wirklich Open Source, oder?
Aber ich verstehe nicht ganz den Zeitpunkt, an dem du sagst, so jetzt ist es nicht mehr Open Source, dann sind doch aber immer noch die Quellen im Netz unterwegs.
Die Urquellen.
Ja und die Leute, die den Code kennen und damit dran gearbeitet haben, werden sicher weiter daran arbeiten. Und ich bezweifle, dass deine Version, die du dann alleine zu Hause weiter vor dich hinhackst, in irgendeiner Weise besser sein wird, als das, was die komplette Open Source Community mit dem Code im Netz danach macht.
Aber ich sehe ja mit der gesamten Community eigentlich, ist ja schon fast eine Community geworden, an einem Programm oder an mehreren Programmen. Und die werden dann auch nicht als wirklich kostenpflichtig im Netz gestellt, sondern als Führer.
Also aber auch die Version, die du jetzt sozusagen zum Verkauf anbietest, ist auch kostenlos herunterladbar?
Achso, das habe ich dich auch verstanden.
Ja, das ist halt ganz cool, weil die Leute halt wissen irgendwie, das ist halt irgendwie Software, die behauptet mehr als nur einer, dass das irgendwie gut ist und er hat auch selber schon mal reingeschaut. Dann ist das natürlich ein ganz anderes Zeugnis für Software. Was macht denn die Software genau?
Na, ich gebe einfach eine Bildgröße ein, also ich 1267, lege irgendeine Formel an, nachdem man den Graphen berechnet, dann berechtigen wir zum Beispiel einen Fragtal. Da ist ein rekursives Fragtal oder ein normales Fragtal.
Wie ist denn die UAL von der Webseite?
www.ploxys.de Und da sind die Produkte dieses Programms drauf. Den Source Code UAL gebe ich nur innerhalb der Community.
Das ist die Source Code?
Also was ist denn die Community, wenn das nur wenige sind?
Das musst du über giga.de, über netcommunity.de immer reinposten.
Also wer ist denn die Community? Also bei mir ist die Community immer die Leute im Internet, die halt auf die Homepage gehen, sich den Source runterladen und wenn er da rein sein will, ist er in der Community. Aber du sagst, du gibst den Source nur an die Community.
Ja.
Wer ist denn die Community?
Ich nehme mich an, ich schicke das Teil rüber, weil ich bin nicht unbedingt das, so wie ich da ist, damit alle rumfummeln. Ich mache mir Sorgen, dass man mit dem Programm Schindluder treibt und dann auf mich zurückführt.
Was ist denn Schindluder treiben mit dem Programm?
Ja, das weiß ich, irgendwelche, also ich kenne Leute, die das betreiben.
Also solche restlichen Probleme lassen sich ziemlich leicht aus der Welt schaffen, indem man sich da die richtige Lizenz aussucht. Dann können die Leute so viel Schindluder mit deinem Programm schreiben, wie sie wollen, dann wird dir niemand dich dafür einwuchten oder...
Wenn du irgendeinen Fehler machst und dir keiner böse Absicht nachweisen kann, dann kann dir auch gar nichts passieren. Da könnt du dich mit deinem Programm Atombomben abschmeißen. Du kannst nicht dafür haftbar gemacht werden.
Ja, das ist eigentlich kein Problem. Habe ich das richtig verstanden, dass es sich dabei um ein Delphi-Programm handelt?
Um ein mit Dolch entwickeltes Programm. Oder mit, ich glaube auch mal, mit dem UHA-Windows-Taskal. War die erste Version zumindest. Und dann immer weiter mit einem neueren Delphi-Version nachbearbeitet.
www.ploxis.de. Marc, wir danken an dieser Stelle für deinen Anruf.
Alles klar, gerne.
Ja, alle anderen, die hier anrufen wollen, können das tun. Wir haben nämlich hier eine Telefonnummer. Das ist eine Sendung, in der man anrufen kann.
0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Das Chaosradio 57 und Open Source und deren Development sind unser Thema.
Anrufen solltet ihr halt, wenn ihr selber Open Source entwickelt. Das würde uns interessieren, was eure Erfahrungen sind, gerade irgendwie, wie ihr das verbreitet und was eure Beeinstellungen zur Lizenzen vor allem in dem Zusammenhang sind.
Was eure Tools sind, was benutzt ihr für Leitzeuge, um das zu machen.
Ich würde auch gerne mal einen Gegner hören. Gibt es Open Source Gegner?
Ja, natürlich, klar. In vielen Firmen gibt es Leute, die der Meinung sind, das ginge halt nicht. Man könnte damit kein Geld verdienen.
Muss man ja auch nicht, sonst hat es ja nicht schon längst funktioniert.
In Firmen will man natürlich Geld verdienen, deswegen gründet man ja eine. Wir haben da halt irgendwie ein bisschen Angst. Wir haben immer diese Angst, wenn unsere Software weg ist, kann die ja jeder kostenlos runterladen. So ein bisschen diese MP3 Angst auch. Und es hat sich halt gezeigt, dass eigentlich da, wo das eben geht, wo die Firmen so offen sind, dass die dadurch gar keinen Nachteil haben. Na klar kann sich jeder die Software runterladen, aber eigentlich die meisten Firmen, die wollen halt auch noch ganz andere Sachen. Die wollen einen Support haben, die wollen irgendwie jemanden haben, wo sie irgendwie anrufen können und der klärt dann das Problem auch zuverlässig mit einem entsprechenden Vertrag. Und da sind sie auch bereit regelmäßig Geld zu zahlen, was natürlich was ganz anderes ist als einmalige Aufwendungen für ein Programm. Wenn so ein Programm 3000 Mark kostet, kaufen das viele Leute nicht. Aber wenn das irgendwie kostenlos ist, dann gucken die halt erstmal, weil kostet ja nichts, stellen dann fest, ah, das kann ich prima gebrauchen. Dann lasse ich sie ein Jahr einsetzen für irgendwas. Vielleicht haben sie auch 100.000 Mark damit verdient. Und dann könnte ich mir zwei Sachen vorstellen. Erstmal, sie kaufen irgendwie das offiziell ein oder geben irgendeine andere Art von Rückgabe, vielleicht indem sie vielleicht sogar selber daran weiterentwickeln und Source Good spenden sozusagen. Oder wenn es jetzt einfach nur eine Firma ist, die das anwendet, dass sie einfach sagt, wir brauchen jetzt aber auch einen Supportvertrag. Weil es gibt da viele, da müssen Leute trainiert werden, da müssen Leute das beigebracht werden. Wir wollen irgendwie spezifische Erweiterungen haben, vielleicht auch noch bestimmte, denizierte Programmierleistungen, um jetzt in der Umgebung, wo sie arbeiten, eben noch mehr rausholen zu können. Anpassungen an andere Programme, was auch immer. Und das hat sich gezeigt, dass viele Firmen mit dem Modell immer leben können. Ein gutes Beispiel ist Cygnus. Cygnus ist eine Firma, die sich, wie seinerzeit, den GCC, also den C-Compiler, der in der Open Source-Szene verwendet wird. Also überhaupt, Unix benutzt irgendwie mittlerweile fast ausschließlich GCC.
Wow, inzwischen benutzt fast jeder GCC.
Jeder benutzt es.
Also das ist das wichtigste Programm überhaupt.
Und die haben einfach diese, haben eine Firma gegründet und gesagt, wir entwickeln das weiter. Aber selbstverständlich entwickeln sie es Open Source weiter. Das heißt nach wie vor ist alles kostenlos und frei. Bloß die Firma hat halt viel Geld damit verdient, dass irgendwelche Prozessorenhersteller auf sie zugekommen sind. Hier, wir möchten das GCC auch auf unserem Satellitensteuerungsprozessor laufen. Pass noch mal an. Und dann schieben die da 200.000 Dollar rüber. Und dann wird das irgendwie auch zuverlässig gemacht. Und auch da steht natürlich wieder allen zur Verfügung. Also das kann funktionieren. Das funktioniert nicht unbedingt in jedem Markt. Aber sogar in den vertikalen Märkten fangen die Leute an ein bisschen umzudenken. Also vertikaler Markt ist halt, wenn man nur eine bestimmte Nische abdeckt. Breiten Software ist natürlich ein ganz anderes Thema.
Ich hoffe, dass selbst da auch funktioniert.
Eine Anmerkung wollte ich noch machen, weil der Junge meine Angerufenheit hat gesagt, er würde halt Freeware irgendwie zur Verfügung stellen. Da muss man halt ruhig mal nachfragen, weil Freeware, das ist so ein bisschen, viele Leute verstehen halt Free wie in Bier, also Freebeam im Sinne von Gratissoftware. Das ist halt das eine. Aber die Frage ist ja auch wirklich, wie ist das mit den Rechten geregelt? Also welche Lizenz ist sozusagen an diesem Source Code angehängt und welche Aussage wird darüber gemacht, wie ich das verwenden kann?
Wo kriege ich den Source Code überhaupt?
Kriege ich den überhaupt? Was darf ich damit tun?
Genau, was darf ich damit tun? Selbst wenn der Source Code da ist, aber da ist eine Lizenz dabei, von dem er es geschrieben hat, die dir quasi nicht erlaubt, irgendeine Änderung anzuminden und da Rechte darauf zu erreichen dadurch. Sondern es bleibt dann immer alles bei diesem Entwickler und das ist kein Open Source. Open Source erlaubt dir halt zu sagen, ich nehme das jetzt und mach damit was ganz anderes, was die Entwickler sich vielleicht auch gar nicht dabei gedacht haben. Und Entwickler ist jetzt in meine eigene Richtung, wo ich hin will. Erscheinlicherweise passiert das nur sehr selten.
Du bist dann aber auch wieder verpflichtet, das weiterzugeben?
Ja, das gibt da... nein, weil es gibt... Nein, nicht bei Open Source, das ist ja der Punkt. Also es gibt diesen Begriff Open Source, der ist jetzt sehr verbreitet mittlerweile, wir benutzen den auch. Ursprünglich redete man eigentlich ausschließlich von Free Software. Gibt es halt irgendwie den jungen Mann, über den wir schon gesprochen haben, Richard Storman, der auch diesen GCC und EMAX und andere Großartigkeiten verbrochen hat vor langer, langer Zeit, weil er einfach wollte, dass alles frei ist. Weil er gesehen hat, dass seine ganzen Hacker-Kollegen, die vorher irgendwie jeden Source-Quot untereinander ausgetauscht haben, jetzt in Firmen gegangen sind und da geht dann irgendwie gar nichts mehr raus. Und er sah einfach das Drama kommen. Hat sich hingesetzt und hat alles irgendwie komplett programmiert. Hat sich alles zur Verfügung gestellt. Und er wollte halt sicherstellen, dass niemand irgendwann mal kommt und sagt, das ist meins. Deswegen hat er sich das Copyright darauf formell auch noch bewahrt. Nur nach dem Motto, das ist auch meins, beziehungsweise es ist der Free Software Foundation. Und die sagt, dass die Verwendung dieser Software ist halt erlaubt, wenn man eben anderen auch auf Anfrage irgendwie den Source-Quot weitergibt. Und dann gibt es noch bestimmte Detailregelungen irgendwie, gegen was man diese Software linken darf und irgendwie, dass sie also nicht mit geschlossener Software sozusagen, mit nicht freier Software irgendwie zusammen verbunden wird, sodass irgendwann auch die freie Software vielleicht nicht mehr frei ist. Das ist eben diese GPL, die GNU Public License, die halt die freiste aller Lizenzen ist, obwohl sie in gewisser Hinsicht auch sehr stringent ist. Dann gab es diese Bewegung, wie heißt noch vielleicht der Open Source Vogel? Wer den Begriff Open Source gebracht hat? Genau, Eric Raymond, der ein recht populärer Vertreter ist in der Szene, der gesagt hat, Open Source ist auch ein ganz tolles Modell für Firmen. Man sollte doch mal darüber nachdenken, das ist nicht nur Hacker-Nischen-Kultur, sondern das ist eigentlich so Big Thing. Sein Argument war, dass dieses ganze offene Entwicklungsmodell natürlich von Vorteil ist. Alles das, was wir hier teilweise auch schon erwähnt haben, noch erwähnen werden. Und da gab es irgendwie einen dicken Streit mit eben Richard Stolman, der da halt sehr religiös und sehr irgendwie stringent ist. Der meinte irgendwie, aber Open Source ist halt nicht freies Software. Denn nach diesem Open Source Modell ist es eben auch in der Firma erlaubt, irgendwie Änderungen an so einem Source Code nicht zu veröffentlichen. Das ist zum Beispiel die BSD-Lizenz. BSD Unix kommt halt nicht unter GPL raus, sondern da gibt es halt die BSD-Lizenz. Und irgendwie klar, man kann den Source Code nehmen, man kann da irgendwelche Änderungen dran machen und man kann die auch verkaufen. Man kann ein Produkt draus machen, Änderungen machen, neue Software mit reinbauen, kann das verkaufen und ich bin nicht gezwungen, den Source Code dafür weiterzugeben, weil GPL ist das anders. Es hat sich halt gezeigt, es gibt da so ein religious war, es hat sich gezeigt, dass beide Modelle funktionieren. Bei BSD Unix kann man das halt ganz gut sehen, obwohl die Leute nicht gezwungen sind es zu tun, geben sie die Software trotzdem weiter, weil das eben die klaren Vorteile sind, weil viele Leute gucken drauf, Leute vertrauen Software mehr, wenn viele Leute draufgeguckt haben, man kriegt Feedback, man kriegt die Leute, die bangen einem das Programm, wie der Anrufer gerade auch schon berichtet hat, die sagen mir ganz genau in welcher Zeit da irgendein Chordam kommt, das ist natürlich alles dann auch Zeit, die ich selber nicht mehr aufwenden muss, ich muss nur noch die Änderungen einpflegen. Bis man dann eben vielleicht sogar so weit geht und sagt, okay, ich entwickle die Software jetzt, ich veröffentliche sie nicht nur, sondern ich entwickle die Software auch mit einer offenen Gemeinde von Leuten, ich stelle den Source Code nicht nur zur Verfügung in einer bestimmten Version, sondern der wird im Netz entwickelt. Viele Leute haben den Zugriff, schreiben den Zugriff auf diesen Source Code und können direkt ohne irgendjemanden fragen, ob sie das auch machen müssen.
So, Chaosradio 57, immer noch Open Source Development. Jetzt schreibe ich hier mein Stück Open Source Software, schmeiß das ins Internet, am besten auch in irgendeine Newsgroup, die sich dann dafür bedanken, dass ich den 350.000 Code Zeilen da reingepostet habe.
Früher war das mal normal.
Ja, früher war auch alles noch besser. Früher waren im Usenet auch Reply-fähige E-Mail Adressen. Jetzt hab ich dieses Stück Software geschrieben und jetzt bedienen sich an diesem Stück Software, lass es tausend Leute nur sein, wahrscheinlich sind es wesentlich mehr. Wo laufen diese ganzen Fäden wieder zusammen? Weil irgendwo muss doch gewissermaßen eine Zentrale sein, sodass jemand sagt, okay, der Browser X, den wir jetzt gerade alle gemeinsam geschrieben haben, ist auf dem neuesten Stand oder auf dem besten Stand, wenn du ihn genau an der Stelle runterlädst. Und genau diese Stelle muss doch dann irgendwie definiert sein. Da muss doch auch eigentlich ein Jemand sitzen oder nicht?
Nicht unbedingt, aber wenn du natürlich so anfängst und deine Software ins Netz stellst, dann bist du erstmal der Jemand. Aber solche Projekte können sich halt auch verselbstständigen und teilweise sind die Leute, die das irgendwann mal ins Leben gerufen haben, auch gar nicht mehr dabei. Und dann finden sich Kleine oder gar nicht mehr im Leben. Also es gibt zwar bei uns im GIMP Projekt eigentlich zwar einen Maintainer, aber der hat eigentlich keine große Aufgabe, außer zu sagen, ich mach jetzt mal einen Release, ich nenne das heute mal so, nachdem ich ein paar Leute gefragt hab, der muss nur die Arbeit machen. Der stellt es danach ins Netz und schreibt die Mailing-Listen an. Und entschieden, was da gemacht wird, wird irgendwie auf Mailing-Listen und wird einfach auch gemacht, die Leute dürfen schreiben, die machen ihre Änderungen.
Und ob es was taugt oder nicht, werden sie schon merken, nämlich, wenn es einer benutzt oder nicht.
Also ich denke, ein erwachsenes Open Source Projekt benutzt eigentlich alle Kommunikationsmittel, die das Internet heutzutage zur Verfügung stellt. Bei Programmierern typischerweise auch die Kryptische, also Newsgroups spielen noch eine sehr große Rolle. Aber in den letzten Jahren, wo Newsgroups überhaupt so angeschwollen sind durch so viele Menschenmassen und so viele Leute, die noch nicht so richtig damit umgehen können, hat sich das mehr auf Mailinglisten verlagert. Das heißt, angenommen, wir starten jetzt ein Open Source Projekt, wir wollen jetzt hier irgendwie ein Fritz-Internet-Gateway bauen. Und dann wollen wir irgendwie das kommunizieren. Dann besetzen wir erstmal eine Webseite auf und sagen, ja hallo, hier ist die Homepage von dem Projekt sowieso, und der Source Code steht hier auf dem FTP-Server. Zum Beispiel. Oder halt im CVS-Server, da kommen wir gleich nochmal drauf zurück. Damit ist das sozusagen, gibt es eine One-Stop-Adresse, wo man irgendwie alle Informationen holt. Da kann man Dokumentationen reinstellen, da kann man irgendwie erstmal sagen, was man eigentlich will, wohin man will, wohin man schon gekommen ist, wer beteiligt ist, E-Mail-Adressen usw. Oder eben dann auch Mailing-Listen, auf die man sich dann vielleicht einschreiben kann. Typischerweise gibt es dann halt eine Mailing-Liste für die Entwickler, wo halt einfach die Entwicklung diskutiert wird, was müsste man mal einbauen, was hätte man schon immer einbauen müssen, oder was sollten wir wieder mal ausbauen. Wo dann halt auch ein Konsens gebildet wird. Teilweise benutzt man natürlich nicht nur die langsamen Diskussionen wie Mail, sondern auch ERC, das ist wie bei euch auch, ziemlich aktiv, du musst es auch nochmal erzählen. Ja, und von Zeit zu Zeit trifft man sich dann vielleicht auch mal auf einer Konferenz oder so, die man vielleicht für dieses Projekt sogar explizit einbrücken würde.
Das heißt, derjenige, der irgendwie die Urversion der Software schreibt, kann sich dann auch letztlich aussuchen, ob eine Bestimmer da ist oder nicht. Also Linux Torwalz behält sich vor zu sagen, was denn der aktuelle Kernel ist. Also welche Version das ist.
Also es gibt den Begriff des Maintainers. Es gibt halt ein oder mehrere Leute, die sozusagen in Charge sind, die sind sozusagen damit beauftragt, dafür zu sorgen, dass diese Software vorankommt, dass da irgendwie Releases gemacht werden und die auch in etwa die Schritte vorgehen, wo es hingeht. Typischerweise übergeben Maintainer das halt dann an andere, wenn sie keinen Bock mehr haben. Es ist eigentlich niemals so, dass irgendjemand das entrissen wird. Man kann natürlich jederzeit auch den Sourcecode nehmen und sagen, die Richtung, die euer Projekt einschlägt, die ist irgendwie gar nicht mein Ding, aber ich nehme jetzt eure Software, weil die ist ja frei, ich kann damit ja machen, was ich will, und mache ein eigenes Projekt. So wie es zum Beispiel bei BSD Unix, es gibt ja nicht nur einen BSD Unix, wie es einen Linux gibt, sondern es gibt auch halt drei oder genau sogar vier. Und die haben alle andere Stoßrichtungen. Die eine BSD ist mehr für Server, das andere kümmert sich mehr darum, dass es auf möglichst vielen Plattformen läuft, und die anderen sind halt so ein bisschen die Sicherheitsfreaks. Sie haben irgendwie alle was gemeinsam, aber sie wissen, sie könnten in einer Projektgruppe alleine gar nicht den Konsens finden, den sie brauchen. Also machen sie es getrennt und übernehmen dann aber so zwischenzeitlich auch immer wieder die Entwicklung der anderen, sodass das alles halbwegs sich auch noch automatisch synchronisiert, ohne dass man das groß planen muss.
Chaosradio 57 mit dem Thema Open Source Development. Ihr könnt uns auch anrufen, denn wir haben Telefonie und wir gehen auch ran. Hier ist unsere Nummer.
0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
Ja und da angerufen hat Uwe, hallo Uwe.
Du hast angerufen.
Ja ich bin nicht Uwe.
Nicht?
Das ist verblüffend. Wer bist denn du?
Gabriel.
Gabriel, hast du dich eben noch Uwe genannt?
Nee, nicht direkt.
Das ist verblüffend. Hast du einen Freund, der Uwe heißt und dir angerufen hat? Na okay, Gabriel. Hast du die Frage gestellt, wozu sind Sachen wie SourceForge gut?
Genau.
Entschuldige, dass ich dich Uwe genannt hab.
Der macht ja nichts.
Der Computer hat dich Uwe genannt.
Stell die Frage nochmal, damit du sie gestellt hast.
Ich wollte halt mal so wissen. Ich bin im Web irgendwie mal auf SourceForge gestoßen und so. Und ich wollte halt mal fragen, wozu solche Sachen genau gut sind.
Also wie das so funktioniert.
Was macht das?
SourceForge bietet dir jetzt außer Source Services wie das dein Projekt, dein Programmierprojekt, eine Homepage und halt einen FTP-Download hat. Einen ganz wichtigen Service, und zwar CVS, was man halt nicht kurz mal von Strato kriegen kann. Ich will eine Website und 100 MB falls zum Downloaden, sondern CVS ist im Wesentlichen eine Mischung aus einem Fileserver wie FTP und einer richtigen temporalen Datenbank, wo quasi jede Version von jeder Änderung jeder Datei gespeichert wird, aber halt immer noch fallbasiert ist. Das Problem ist folgendes, ich habe ein Programm, das besteht aus 100 Dateien. Ich stelle die ins Netz, das lädt sich irgendjemand runter, ändert das und will, dass ich die Änderung einbaue. Jetzt habe ich zur gleichen Zeit an der gleichen Stelle was geändert und dann sieht das alles ganz furchtbar aus und das geht einfach nicht. Deswegen braucht man einen zentralen Ort, wo das Programm einfach auf einem Server liegt, weil man sich immer die aktuelle Version, aber auch jede alte Version rausziehen kann. Und es gibt Leute, die haben Schreibzugriff auf dem Server und können halt Änderungen an dem Programm vornehmen. Und das ist mit das allerwichtigste Tool für die Open Source Entwicklung. Das kann man auch jedem empfehlen, der zu Hause alleine entwickelt.
Was heißt SourceForge?
Ja, CVS hits im ersten Sinne. SourceForge ist eigentlich ein ganz tolles Ding, weil es ist ein Angebot von einer Firma in Amerika, die einen dicken Server haben, die verkaufen Lienungshardware, die können sich das leisten, da sowas hinzustellen. Und die bieten halt hier eine Projekthomepage anmelden. Du kriegst dein projekt.sourceforge.net Webadresse, du kriegst ein FDP-Download, du kriegst einen CVS Server, du kriegst Mailinglisten, ein Forum, wo man online diskutieren kann, alles was man halt so braucht.
Ach, Tracking, das ist volle Programm.
Und CVS ist halt... CVS ist eben wirklich...
Deine Frage ist erstmal beantwortet, oder Gabriel?
Ok, danke für deinen Anruf. Falls noch jemand anrufen will, hier.
0331 für Potsdam, 7097110.
Also, ja, das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Und die Frage ist ja, wie fange ich an? Man hat halt seine eigene Programmierumgebung in der Regel. Das kann unter welchem Betriebssystem auch immer sein. Wenn man sich nicht nur entschieden hat, seinen Source Code einmal in einer Version zur Verfügung zu stellen, dann können die anderen Leute mal gucken. Man möchte auch, dass die aktiv dran mitarbeiten. Dann braucht man einen zentralen Server, der den Source Code vorhält und der das incrementelle Ändern, also das Ändern an einzelnen kleinen Stellen erlaubt. Und da hat sich halt ein System unter dem Namen CVS durchgesetzt im Open Source Bereich. Das steht für Concurrent Versioning System. Und es erlaubt einem in einem Baum von Dateien, der der komplette Source Tree ist von dem Projekt, kann man sich alle erstmal auf die Platte kopieren. Dann guckt man sich raus, was man eben ändern will. Dann geht man einfach mit dem Editor rein, macht seine Änderung, speichert die ab, testet es vielleicht. Und wenn man der Meinung ist, okay, das war jetzt irgendwie eine Änderung, die ist signifikant, das sollte in das Projekt mit einfließen. Dann kann ich einen sogenannten Commit durchführen. Das heißt, ich bestätige die Änderung. Das heißt, Software auf meinem Rechner nimmt Kontakt auf mit dem Server und sagt, hallo, hier ist eine Änderung für die Datei sowieso, spiel die doch bitte mal rein. Es ist nicht so, dass er einfach die Dateien ersetzt und die neue Version nimmt. Er macht einen Vergleich zwischen der Ursprungsversion der Datei, als er das heruntergeladen hat, und der geänderten Version und sieht genau, wo ist eine Zeile dazugekommen, wo sind welche gelöscht worden, was hat sich irgendwie hier und da geändert und speichert jetzt die Änderung und nicht die volle Datei. Zählt eine interne Versionsnummer hoch, sodass andere Leute eben nicht nur diese Änderung auch noch genau sehen, wo ist diese Änderung erfolgt, wer hat sie gemacht, wann hat er sie gemacht. Man fügt in der Regel beim Einchecken, also beim Einspielen der Änderung auch noch einen Kommentar mit hinzu, indem man dann halt möglichst ausführlich dazu Stellung nehmen sollte, warum man das jetzt gemacht hat, weil das wird ja nicht unbedingt aus jeder Änderung sofort selber ersichtlich. Und das steht natürlich anderen sofort zur Verfügung. Man kann auch schon relativ bequem im Web irgendwie über die Änderung rüberbrausen und man sieht dann halt schön farbig, vorher war es irgendwie so und dann kam Benutzer sowieso, der hat die und die Änderung gemacht und zwar weil das und das. Und so ergänzt sich das. Andere Leute können dann diese Änderung relativ einfach auf ihrer Platte draufsynchronisieren. Das heißt nur diese Änderung wird dann irgendwie in die Datei mit eingespielt, vielleicht selber gerade modifiziert hat, sodass man eben während man programmiert die ganze Zeit alle Änderungen von allen anderen Programmierern auch automatisch mit überspielt bekommt.
Am Dienstag in den Radio Fritzen am Morgen.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Das Wetter. Nachts gebietsweise nebelartig glätte um 0 Grad, morgen das kalt höchste hätte zwischen 2 und 4 Grad. War das das, was du mir mit den Wurzeln mitteilen wolltest?
Die Meldung mit falschen Zielen.
Die zuständigen Landesminister für Verbraucherschutz haben sich auf eine gemeinsame Linie bei der Rinderkrankheit BSE verständigt. Versitzungen in Bremen forderten die Minister, die Bundesregierung auf, die BSE-Forschung zu verstärken und die Schnelltests auf alle Schlachttiere auszuweiten. Zudem sollten Medikamente und Antibiotika in der Tierzucht verboten werden. Im Zuge der Bundeswehrreform sollen 59 Standorte geschlossen werden. Nach den Vorstellungen von Verteidigungsminister Scharping bleiben die Länder Berlin und Brandenburg von Schließungen zwar verschont, allerdings sollen die Stützpunkte in Brück, Strausberg und Cottbus verkleinert werden. Nach dem schweren Erdbeben im Westen Indiens besteht kaum noch Hoffnung für die rund 100.000 Vermissten. Die Retter konnten heute nur noch wenige Überlebende aus den Trümmern befreien. Die Medien sprachen von bis zu 35.000 Toten. In Berlin sollen alle öffentlichen Schwimmbäder auf einen möglichen Fall durch legionellen Bakterien untersucht werden. Das kündigte die Gesundheitsverwaltung an. Die Behörden reagierten damit auf die Entdeckung der Krankheitserreger, die bereits zur Schließung von drei Schwimmhallen geführt haben.
Uns zwar um 23.33. Danke, Falz.
Aber nicht einfach so, sondern besser, dicker und bunter als... Ankel Fritz gibt's ab dem 1. Februar mit jedem Ankel-Cellys-Heft.
Einfach vorne draufgeklebt.
48 Seiten stark und echt was drin. Party-Tipps. Musik-Infos.
Und...
Anjas Party-Geflüster. Schwarz auf Weiß. Februar überall, wo es das 1.
Magazin gibt.
Geschrieben und aufgeklebt von...
Sieh mal, wir wollten nochmal auf CVS eingehen, weil das gerade vorher so eine schöne Vorrede von Tim war. Und daran kann man sehr schön erläutern, wie eigentlich das ganze Unix Programmierzeug funktioniert. Das ist nämlich eine Toolbox, sagt man dazu, weil CVS ist ja ein schönes System denkbarstich, da kann man irgendwie Dateien übers Netz vergleichen und was für eine Wahnsinnsfunktionalität. Da haben Leute bestimmt Jahrhunderte dran gehackt und genau so ist es auch. Das beruht nämlich seinerseits wiederum auf ein System, das heißt RCS, das ist ein Programm, das ist auch ein ganz normales Unix Programm und das macht dasselbe wie CVS, nur halt lokal auf meiner Platte, ohne Netzwerk, ohne Internet. Einfach ich leg meine Version in einer großen Datei an und die Datei weiß, wie die verschiedenen Versionen sind über die Zeit. Dieses RCS beruht wiederum auf so anderen, noch viel kleineren Programmen wie DIV und Patch. DIV zeigt mir einfach den Unterschied zwischen zwei Dateien, was Tim vorher schön erklärt hat, dass der Output im Netz bunt und farbig erscheint. Irgendwo da ganz unten ist so ein altes Unix-Programm, was es schon immer gegeben hat. Was es schon immer gegeben hat? Ja, so vom Anliegen der Unix-Zeiten praktisch.
DIV kann allgemeine vergleichende Literaturwissenschaften auf EDV-Ebene durchführen?
Ja, ein bisschen weiter unten. Das nimmt einfach zwei Dateien, vergleicht die und was rauskommt, der Output ist in ein Format, dass man es in ein Programm reinstecken kann. Das heißt Patch, Patch wie Englisch verflicken. Und dieses Patch-File macht dann aus der einen Datei die andere Datei, die man miteinander verglichen hat. Auf solchen kleinen Bausteinen beruht halt die ganze Magie und das Voodoo von CVS. Und so ist es bei Unix einfach oft. Man hat seine Toolbox, man hat kleine Programme, die ein well-defined Feature-Set haben, die einfach funktionieren und nicht übermäßige, eierlegende Wäume oder Monster, die irgendwelche komischen Sachen machen und dann halberig gut do one thing, but do it good. Das ist die ganze Philosophie, die dahintersteckt. Genau.
Ihr macht ja auch was irgendwie. Ich meine, ihr...
Ach so, Mitch.
Wir Mitch und Sven sind ja irgendwie ganz aktiv am Hacken irgendwie im Open Source Bereich. Und zwar ein Programmchen namens GIMP. Wo kommt das denn her?
GIMP ist ein Bildbearbeitungsprogramm und hat auch inzwischen schon ein paar Jährchen auf dem Buckel. Das ist entstanden 1995 in Berkeley, in Amerika, in der Uni. Da haben sich zwei zusammengesetzt und gesagt, wir müssen mal irgendwas programmieren, was wirklich Spaß macht, was wir schon immer haben wollten. Wir wollen Bilder ins Netz stellen und wollen das mit unserer eigenen Software machen. Und die haben sich hingesetzt und haben ziemlich schnell was zusammengestellt, was schon ganz beachtlich war. Schon damals ein bisschen in Richtung Photoshop ging und haben das ins Netz gestellt. Und sie hatten ein Plug-in-System, schon damals, und die Leute konnten halt anfangen und konnten irgendwelche Effekte dafür schreiben. Und das ging richtig ab, also das ging ganz schnell. Und da war schon ein richtig brauchbares Tool zusammen. Und es gab endlich irgendetwas, womit man unter Linux auf seinem Desktop, wo es noch ziemlich leer war zu der Zeit, aus der Netzgab gab es da nicht viel. Endlich mal was machen.
Das war echt eine Offenbarung. Zum ersten Mal GIMP gesehen, und Linux sah plötzlich ganz anders aus. Irgendwie ist ein Programm mit bunten Knöpfen klicken, und dann ist das Bild plötzlich farbig. Das gab es einfach davor nicht.
Das gibt es auch für Windows. Wird das dann auch farbig?
Natürlich.
Ich habe übrigens gerade noch eine Mail gekriegt an chaosradio.fritz.de. Das Serverbetriebssystem von Hotmail ist FreeBSD.
Ja, wie die meisten großen Server.
Das ist doch das Daneben, oder?
Auch Jahomo verwendet FreeBSD, und viele große Websites fahren FreeBSD ganz einfach, weil es das Stabilste von allen OSen ist. Also stabiler als ich will jetzt hier keinen Religionskrieg hervorbringen, aber die werden schon ihre Gründe haben.
Hotmail ist ja auch nur gekauft von Microsoft.
MSBSD hatte ich gerade im Kopf. Hier ist gerade KM50 auf Fritz mit dem Thema Open Source Development. Das ist so eine Sendung, wo man anrufen kann unter den...
031 für Potsdam, 70 97 110.
So wie... Oh, Sebastian das getan hat. Hallo Sebastian. Sebastian? Versuch mal mit Patrick.
Ja, also ich programmier SPS allerdings so eher für Industriellizenz.
Möb, Möb, stopp, was ist das?
Eine speicherprogrammierbare Schaltung. Speicherprogrammierbare Schaltung. Was ist das denn?
Ansteuerungssysteme für Maschinenbau und andere Sachen.
Ach so, die berühmte alte CNC-Fräse, ja?
Genau, die CNC-Fräse.
Ja, ja gut, aber dann kann wenigstens ich auch mit mir was darunter vorstellen.
Du hast so eine CNC-Fräse zu Hause und so ein gar nicht steueres Computer.
Also mal angenommen, ich würde jetzt neue PID-Regler entwickeln für irgendwelche Farbmischanlagen oder sowas. Und ich würde die auch frei ins Netz stellen. Das finde ich ja alles ganz toll. Aber wovon soll ich denn noch leben? Denn verkauft es irgendjemand anderes, wesentlich preisgünstiger als ich.
Na du kannst natürlich die Lizenz, mit der du das veröffentlicht, kannst du ja selber bestimmen. Wenn das jetzt für dich irgendwie ein großes Drama erscheint, dann kannst du das irgendwie natürlich auch unter der Bedingung veröffentlichen, dass es nur nicht kommerziell verwendet werden darf. Das heißt, die Leute dürfen es zwar nehmen, benutzen, ausprobieren und alles damit machen, es auch weitergeben, aber eben nicht verkaufen. So, jetzt kannst du natürlich noch die Angst ins Feld schieben. Na ja, aber wenn er es trotzdem tut. Letzten Endes ist es so, dass die Leute eigentlich eben mehr schätzen, direkt an der Quelle zu sein. Das heißt, wenn du derjenige bist, der die Software geschrieben hat, dann können zwar andere das sogar auch verkaufen, aber du kannst auf jeden Fall besser Fehler finden. Weil du kennst die Software, du weißt, was sie tut, und wenn sie irgendwie halbwegs komplex ist und nicht zu trivial, wenn sie zu trivial wäre, dann hätte sie auch keinen Verkaufswert, aber wenn sie irgendwie eine gewisse Dienstleistung erfüllt, mag eben der potenzielle Gründer das natürlich. Warum sollte ich bei jemand anderem kaufen, wenn ich auch bei dir kaufen kann?
Ja, na ja, so, nun da stellt sich mir die Frage, ob ich den meinen Kunden zum Beispiel das klar machen kann, dass sie eben dort nur offene Software von mir bekommen, die jeder verwenden kann und dass sie dafür dein Geld bezahlen sollen.
Ist es in der Regel so, dass du die Software einmal installierst und dann gehst du aus der Halle und dann war es das und es läuft dann ewig weiter?
Dafür ist es ja auch gedacht, wenn ich jede Woche einmal hinkommen muss, dann hab ich irgendwas falsch gemacht.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich. Ja, gut, also bestimmte Bereiche eignen sich sicherlich besser und manche etwas weniger für Open Source. Letzten Endes könntest du natürlich immer noch den Aspekt haben, dass du eben auch mit mehreren Leuten an einer Software arbeitest. Also das musst du selber entscheiden. Es gibt da nicht die goldene Antwort. Ich denke auch nicht, dass Open Source die goldene Antwort auf alles ist, aber es löst eine ganze Menge Probleme, die man eben mit Proprietärerssoftware durchaus hat.
Viele von den Leuten, die dort da beliefert werden, wahrscheinlich auch nicht die Kenntnisse haben, das Bessicht zu installieren. Du wirst ja nicht nur dafür bezahlt, das zu programmieren, sondern auch hinzugehen und das ist ein Gesamtfund.
Kenntnisse über ihre Maschinen und ihre Anlagen haben sie schon. Sie würden das dann zur Not auch hinbekommen und das selber, sich zu kopieren, wenn sie sich eine neue Maschine kaufen oder sowas, das eben da halt einfach zu kopieren. Nur die nächste Frage wäre, gibt es so eine Lizenz, also schon vorherfertigt oder müsste ich mir jetzt selber eine machen?
Gute Frage.
Also, kannst du mal...
Es gibt eine ganze Menge Lizenzen natürlich und auch Info über Lizenzen im Netz. Aber es ist wirklich schwierig, manchmal auch die Richtige dann zu finden. Weil dieser Software, weiß ich nicht, ob da GPL so angebracht wäre, aber es wäre zwar schon eine Möglichkeit, sich davor zu schützen, dass jemand anders sagt, bei gutem Verkauf ich es eben, wenn er es ins Netz stellt. Das kannst du damit halt definitiv ausschließen. Allerdings kannst du es eigentlich auch nie wieder selber verkaufen. Ein Vorteil könnte halt zum Beispiel sein, dass andere Leute daran mitentwickeln, dass es wirklich richtig gut wird und du Anfragen viel mehr kriegst als früher Spezialanwendungen dafür zu machen. Anpassungen an bestimmte Maschinen, weil das ja wahrscheinlich doch nicht immer dasselbe Programm ist.
Also ich meine, du kannst einfach mal mit deinen Kunden reden. Das würde ich dir empfehlen. Ich meine, wie die das sehen, weil ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass die eigentlich gar nicht so eine Lust haben, sich auf irgendwas zu verlassen. Weil angenommen, du stellst jetzt irgendwie Software X, stellst du ins Netz. Jetzt kommen zwei, drei Leute, die irgendwie in diesem Bereich irgendwie finnisch sind oder eben auch vielleicht der Kunde selber. Kann ich ja runterladen. Ich schätze meinen Kundenkreis als so ein bisschen als so Leute ein, die eigentlich irgendwie Sicherheit über alles. Und die wollen auch jemanden haben, den sie auf den Kopf schlagen können, dafür wenn irgendwas nicht geht. Und in dem Moment, wo sie sozusagen sich was aus dem Netz holen, einfach auch gar nicht das Vertrauen, vielleicht auch berechtigt gar nicht das Vertrauen aufbringen, dass es sich wirklich jetzt um die Software handelt, die auf ihren Maschinen wirklich genau läuft. Das hat ja auch viel mit Beratung zu tun. Du musst ja vorher mit den Leuten sprechen, was sie eigentlich haben wollen. Und in der Regel ist es ja immer eine spezifische Anpassung, oder sehe ich das falsch?
Ja, meistens ist es eine spezifische Anpassung. Nur diese spezifische Anpassung, die kann dann eigentlich schon so gut wie fast jeder wieder machen. Also das sind dann ein paar Parameter, die zu ändern sind an einem Regler. Aber so der Grund, so einen Regler zu programmieren, der dann, was weiß ich, wo denn nur noch ein paar Parameter zu ändern sind, ja, da sitzt man dann erstmal 200 Stunden dran. Ja, und den kann man dann aber universell einsetzen.
Du hast da sicherlich auch schon Software irgendwie gemacht, die heute so gar nicht mehr zum Einsatz kommt, weil die einfach gar nicht mehr marktfähig wäre, oder?
Na ja, ich hab immer drauf aufgebaut. Ich hab's so gestaltet, dass ich immer weiter anbauen kann. Von daher läuft auch noch Software von vor acht Jahren.
Wenn du irgendwie den Drang verspürst, dass auch andere Leute in die Früchte deiner Arbeit kommen sollten, dann hast du ohnehin schon mal einen Triebfeder darüber nachzudenken. Ob das jetzt irgendwie aus den Erwägungen eines Business Modells für dich jetzt größere Chancen bietet als das, was du bisher tust, kann man schwer abschätzen. Das hängt immer sehr viel mit der Szene zusammen, mit der man dann auch konkret zu tun hat, wie die so drauf sind und was die eigentlich haben wollen, wofür sie eigentlich bereit sind zu bezahlen. Und dann muss natürlich jeder seine Entscheidung machen. Also Open Source wird das andere Modell nicht ablösen, sondern es wird wie immer beides geben. Und der Übergang dazwischen ist dann eben auch diffus. Auf jeden Fall.
Patrick, danke für deinen Anruf.
Ja, das war auch eine berechtigte Frage. Das haben sich vor ein paar Jahren auch viele schon gefragt, wie soll denn das gehen und so weiter. Und dann sind sie halt alle drauf eingeschwenkt. So, Sun irgendwie hat dieses Star Office gekauft und hat sich mittlerweile sogar dazu durchgerungen, das als GPL zu veröffentlichen. Deren Kalkül ist natürlich, dass einfach ihre Unix-Plattform konkurrenzfähig sein soll zu Windows. Dazu brauchst du auf jeden Fall eine Office-Soft für heutzutage im Businessbereich. Die Leute kaufen allein schon deshalb Windows, weil es Office gibt. Und haben sich gesagt, naja Gott, wir können jetzt irgendwie anfangen, mit Textverarbeitung irgendwie Geld zu verdienen. Könnten aber auch einfach mal die Scheiß-Software aufs Netz schmeißen, frei. Und dann entwickelt sich das irgendwie selber, weil die Leute sind einfach geil auf eine Office-Software unter Unix. Und dann ist das einfach ein Gewinn, der sich auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise für uns auszahlt. Das ist natürlich ein Kalkül, so eine große Firma eben an der Stelle anstellt. Das ist auch berechtigt. Und das hat ja auch einen konkreten Nutzen. Von daher alles andere als verwerflich.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio 1750 auf dem Netz. Wo war mal stehen geblieben?
Bei der Ruhigkeitsstunde?
Wir distanzieren uns von den anderen.
Wir haben gerade ein angeregtes Gespräch darüber, ob man jetzt irgendwie sein Businessmodell ändert. Gerade so die Frage von einzelnen Softwareentwicklern, die halt wirklich als Freelancer überleben. Ich kenne auch einige, die das sehr wohl tun. Die arbeiten natürlich dann nicht gerade in so einem Bereich wie SPS-Steuerung. Das ist natürlich schon ein besonderer Fall.
Das ist ein haariges Gebiet.
Ja, ja, es gibt halt viele Leute, die sehr wohl irgendwie eben genauso arbeiten. Die haben einen, vielleicht einfach so ein eigenes Projekt, so eine eigene Software, die vielen Leuten irgendwie zugutekommt. Und das bringt, da stecken sie viel Arbeit rein, relativ viel. Lesen auch dann auf den entsprechenden Mailing-Listen, reden den ganzen Tag mit irgendwelchen Leuten, obwohl sie eigentlich was ganz anderes zu tun haben, hacken aber trotzdem parallel in der Software weiter. Und dann kann man sich fragen, na okay, was hat er denn davon? Na er hat einiges davon. Erstmal hat er ein lebendiges Projekt, wo viele Leute Feedback geben und mit am Code debuggen, das ist natürlich ein ganz anderes entwickeln, da lernt man einfach besser. Zweitens befriedigt es natürlich auch deutlich mehr, weil man einfach sehr viel direkten Kontakt zu den Leuten hat, die dann entsprechend auch Dankbarkeit ausdrücken in der Regel. Darüber hinaus bringt es natürlich auch einfach einen guten Ruf. Und das ist einfach deutlich mehr wert als alles andere. Man könnte von einem Reputation-based System reden, so wie das im Netz auch ist. Wem glaubt man? Leuten, die auch schon vorher kluge Sachen von sich gegeben haben. Wessen Software vertraut man? Leute, die natürlich Software schreiben, die viele Leute benutzen. Und irgendwie positive Kommentare dazu abgeben. So kann man sich halt selbst bekannt machen. Und sowohl den Leuten irgendwie kostenlos was geben und so ein bisschen sein Selbst damit befriedigen, als eben auch seinen Marktwert automatisch dadurch zu erhöhen. Ohne, dass man jetzt gezwungen ist, irgendwelche rabiaten Preise für seine Software einzuklagen, was meistens eher ein Hindernis ist, um die Software zu zubereiten.
Wir haben noch einen Anrufer.
Hallo, Eris.
Hallo?
Eris? Aber ein hübscher Name, immerhin.
Ich spüre es in meiner Zirbeldrüse.
Irgendwie glaube ich dir es nicht. Ach, da ist Eris wieder. Ah, der ist rausgeflogen gewesen. Eris?
Nachdem ich jetzt zweimal rausgeschmissen wurde?
Warum?
Ja, und zwar zwei Fragen. Einmal, es ging ja die ganze Zeit um OSD, Open Source Development. Und da wollte ich eigentlich mal eine Frage haben bezüglich Anfang. Damit sollte man ja am besten schon anfangen, direkt in der Schule damit zum Beispiel. Und das ist allerdings so, dass wir kommerziell eher geschult werden als frei. Denn wir kriegen kostenlose Windlust, Distributionen etc.
Zum Mit nach Hause nehmen nach der Schule auch?
Na ja, sie verlieren sich in unseren Taschen.
Ich dachte, es würde euch explizit gestattet, die dann auch mit nach Hause zu nehmen. Weil das wäre dann noch sehr ehrenhaft.
Nein, aber wir haben wirklich für jeden Rechner Heizenden kostenlos gekriegt. Allerdings habe ich irgendwann mal gelesen. Dass es für einen Sonderpreis fünf Debian Lizenzen gibt. Und das hat mich dann doch etwas sehr stark verwundert. Denn eigentlich ist es doch umgekehrt, oder?
Du kannst ja Debian so oft wie du willst völlig umsonst als Netz runterladen. Und da kann kein Mensch dafür Geld verdienen.
Du kannst es Millionen mal installieren und es kostet genau gar nichts.
Genau.
Und zwar mal von dem Bereich Computing und so weiter abgesehen. Die DPL lässt sich ja ausweiten auf praktisch alle Bereiche, wenn man das will. Nun stellt sich die Frage, wer bezahlt das Ganze? Naja, Beispiel, Kunst, irgendwas. Man hat irgendwas produziert und stellt vor, ja, frei, das ist frei und wenn ihr wollt, dass wir das dabei euch vorstellen, dann müsst ihr halt Anfahrt und so weiter bezahlen. Aber ich denke mal, es finden sich extrem wenige Menschen, die das wirklich machen.
Ja gut, ich mein, wir sind jetzt vom Thema her urheberrecht, das haben wir vor dem letzten Mal schon besprochen. Das heißt nicht, dass ich da nicht drauf eingehen möchte, also es ist ein weites Feld, die GPL erlaubt es dir auf jeden Fall relativ effizient Sachen frei ins Netz zu stellen und eben auch sicherzustellen, dass es frei bleibt, wenn das dein Wunsch ist. Wenn du jetzt irgendwie dieses konkrete Geldverdienen Problem hast mit dem, was du tust, also wenn es irgendwie dein künstlerischer Output ist und den möchtest du gerne gesichert wissen, was ja ein legitimer Anspruch ist, dann muss man sich halt andere Modelle überlegen, das findet derzeit statt, da hat eigentlich noch keiner irgendwie das goldenen Kalb irgendwie rausgezogen, da gibt es nicht die eine Antwort, da gibt es viele Antworten. Man kann halt schauen, kann ich irgendwie, auch wenn ich meine Sachen frei ins Netz stelle, trotzdem überleben, weil ich eben, was weiß ich, für Performances geladen werde oder einfach ein toller Typ bin und irgendwie überall hofiert werde oder irgendwie die Leute mir auch so Geld überweisen. Trio hat irgendwann mal auf der zweiten CD die Kontor-Nummer veröffentlicht, ich weiß nicht, ob das was gewirkt hat.
Ich bin interessante Frage.
Vorher haben sie die Telefonnummer veröffentlicht, da haben alle angerufen. So und wenn es nicht geht, dann ist es vielleicht noch nicht das Modell. GPL ist, naja, du hast gesagt, man könnte GPL auf alles übertragen. Wenn man die GPL selber durchsieht, merkt man schon, da geht es extrem um Software. Da gibt es auch viele Begrifflichkeiten drin und Paragrafen, die irgendwie ganz konkret auf Software und was irgendwie das Wesen von Software ist eingehen, sodass es sich nicht ohne weiteres übertragen lässt. Aber es gibt andere Modelle, wie zum Beispiel Open Content License. Da kannst du unter www.opencontent.org nachschlagen, wo halt auch Leute irgendwie dieses Modell, der ich stelle, eine Information frei zur Verfügung, das auch in eine Lizenz gegossen haben und andere Ansätze. Bei den Künstlern, das stellt sich ja auch gerade die Frage mit dem ganzen MP3 Kram. Wie kommen wir eben an unsere Kohle? Die Diskussion ist halt insofern auch noch verworren, weil eben viele Leute das Modell, wie es eben heute existiert, als de facto gegeben ansehen und noch nicht wirklich den Kopf frei haben, um wirklich ein komplett neues Modell sich einfallen zu lassen. Weil letzten Endes, den Moment, wo alle Leute sich darauf anpassen, wird sich nur ein System am Leben erhalten können, was eben genug Revenue für Künstler oder wer auch immer dazu beiträgt, generiert. Das wird schon kommen.
Also ist die GPL und was es auch immer für Lizenzen dort gibt, praktisch nur an dem guten Glauben und Herzen des Menschen ausgerichtet?
Na ja, es ist halt eine Vision für diese Welt. Es ist die Vision, dass eben bestimmte Dinge frei sein sollten. Denn wenn sie es nicht sind, dann ist es irgendwie ein Drama. Und das ist das, was diese Szene formuliert und was sie eben auch konkret realisiert. Und indem sie eben Software mit GPL oder eben verwandten Lizenzen ins Netz stellen.
Ja, dass ich nun meine Fragen eigentlich gänzlich durch meinen Vollgänger erledigt haben. Ich frage vorher schon dran, Freust du? Ja, einfach auch einen schönen Abend. Und ja, Linux Lehrgänge sollten etwas weiter verbreitet sein.
Auf jeden Fall in den Schulen.
Ja, also wir hören wirklich nur von Windows und Delphi.
Was für eine Schule ist das?
Das ist ein sehr tolles Gymnasium, dessen Namen ich lieber nicht nennen sollte.
Ja, aber halt ein Gymnasium und da wird irgendwie richtig Programmierunterricht gegeben, aber eben unter Windows mit Delphi.
Ja, nach einem Lehrplan von 1994.
Na ja gut, also ich kann dir Gymnasien zeigen, da steht noch nicht mal ein Computer. Falls der irgendwo steht, steht ein Sekretariat.
Na ja, nur weil es bei den anderen schlimmer ist, muss es ja dran nicht sein.
Na ja, man kann aber immer doch das kleinere Übel wählen, oder?
Ja, na ja, ich meine, ihr solltet halt irgendwie massiv darauf drängen, dass vielleicht irgendwie mindestens mal ein Rechner auch mit was anderem ausgestattet wird wie Windows.
Ja, na ja, sagen wir es mal so, es waren einige Rechner mit Linux ausgestattet, aber nun waren die Lehrer sehr abhängig darauf, dass Linux runtergeschmissen sollte und auf einem 286er mit einem nach eingebauten CD-Rumlaufwerk ein Windows 95 zum Laufen gebracht werden sollte.
Aha, werden die von Microsoft bezahlt, eure Lehrer? Ja, das klang so, also...
Nee, aber die sind wirklich sehr abhängig darauf, Windows 95 und dann TR so.
Na ja, wahrscheinlich weil sie nichts anderes kennen. Ja, das ist halt dann immer der Trick. Ja, dann müsst ihr die Macht übernehmen.
Ja, ich bin die Einzige.
Na, das ist doch schon mal ein Anfänger.
Dann machst du eine Revolution jetzt und machst den anderen schmackhaft. Iris, danke für deinen Anruf. Der Tim.
Das Lied fängt mit nichts an.
Jetzt du auch mal mitspielen.
Nicht meine.
Kann ich auch was sagen? Ich muss aber echt auf jeden Fall kurz an das auf Englisch sagen, weil ich benutze gerade nämlich unser Hauptkommunikationstool des IAC und bin jetzt nach endlosen Mühen mit diesem komischen Netz hier.
Euer heißt für GIMP.
GIMP, unser GIMP IAC Kanal. And, hi Josh, do you hear me? I finally managed to say something in English. Jetzt ist der Stream endlich über den Atlantik rüber.
Anyone who wants to call this show can do this. 00493317097110.
00493317097110.
Hier ist auf Fritz das Chaosradio 57 mit Open Source Development. Was ist das für Musik denn? Non Place Urban Fields. Genau.
Oder Non Place Urban Fields, das weiß ich nicht ganz klar. Ah, Non Place Urban Fields. Und ein Berliner Projekt.
Unser kleiner englischer Exkurs eben, der war übrigens, um tatsächlich jemanden wo zu grüßen, Mitch?
Die ganzen Amis. Die sitzen in Berkeley und in den komischsten Orten und hören uns jetzt hier zu. Und die Antwort kam auch prompt irgendwie auf mein Hallo nach Amerika, kam auch prompt hier irgendwie über einen anderen Kanal zurück im IRC.
Das ist doch alles albern. Die Welt dreht sich viel zu schnell.
In welchem Channel bist du da jetzt drin?
Ja GIMP vermutlich.
Ich bin im GIMP-Channel, das ist auf IRC Mint nett.
Und die Jungs in Berkeley, die basteln jetzt gerade an GIMP rum und...
Ja, das ist eigentlich nur ein Beispiel. Genau.
Das ist halt der Ort, wo eben auch über das Development geregelt wird.
Wie viele Arbeiten da dran? Gibt es da Zahlen? Also wie viele Leute außer euch beiden Arbeiten an GIMP?
Das ist ein gutes Problem vor allem, vor denen ich daran gearbeitet habe.
Also das sind sicher schon einige hunderte, die in irgendeiner Weise dazu beigetragen haben, wenn man in irgendeiner Weise dazu reicht, wahrscheinlich sogar tausende, die irgendwo mal ein kleines Tutorial geschrieben haben, das ins Netz gestellt haben, irgendwo mal ein Plakin geschrieben haben, ein Skript oder einfach nur gesagt haben, hier, da ist ein Fehler oder wie wärs denn da mal mit dem Feature.
Und konkret Programmierer?
Das ist immer so eine Truppe von irgendwie fünf bis zehn Leuten, die so im Kern dabei sind, die so die Hauptarbeit machen und das hat halt über die Jahre auch ein bisschen gewechselt.
Also das Contributors Fall, das ich hier gerade hab, das spricht ja von 150 Leuten etwa.
Lebt ihr davon in irgendeiner Form oder ist das Hobby?
Das ist schon Hobby, klar. Allerdings noch natürlich irgendwie guten Job. Wenn du erstmal in so einem Open Source Projekt drin bist und das großes Open Source Projekt ist, dann ist das halt wirklich kein Problem.
Ich bin. Okay, GNU Image Manipulation Program, GIMP, beziehungsweise Tim.
Ja, manche sagen auch GIMP ist my Photoshop.
Genau, damit wäre es ein rekursives Akronym wie GNU.
Ja.
Was ist das, Mitch?
Das ist ein allround Bildbearbeitungsprogramm für pixelmanipulierte, also für pixelbasierte Bilddaten. Das ist kein Vektorprogramm, sondern ein Pixelprogramm wie Photoshop. Und man soll natürlich nicht verschweigen, dass er zum Beispiel keine Vierfarbsseparation für die Druckendstufe kann irgendwie. Aber es ist für Webgrafik irgendwie das Tool der Wahl. Absolut. Und nicht nur aus der Vindos-Stolz, sondern es ist auch wirklich so.
Es ist auch tatsächlich besser als Photoshop oder was?
Für Webgrafiken würde ich sagen, gibt es kein besseres Tool.
Und gibt es auch auf Windows mittlerweile, hab ich gesehen.
Ja, die aktuelle Version ist jetzt so in der 1-2er Version, die wir Weihnachten rausgebracht haben, zeitgleich quasi auch Windows erschienen.
Und die ist auch stabil und läuft ordentlich und niemand darf mehr behaupten, dass es für Windows nichts ordentliches gibt.
Ne, wir haben jetzt gesagt, dass es stabil ist, das ist jetzt so.
Den Trick müsst ihr mir bei Zeit mal beibringen.
Wie deklariert es da eben.
Ja und wir haken natürlich auch schon wieder an der nächsten Version.
Was fehlt euch noch? Fehlt euch da irgendwie was dran? Oder sind das jede Menge Feinheiten, Kleinigkeiten, die ihr da jetzt irgendwie dran rumpasst?
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich immer so, wenn man an so einem großen Projekt arbeitet. Wenn man es von außen sieht, dann ist es ein schönes Programm mit Fenstern und alles. Wenn man sich wirklich damit auskennt und reinguckt, dann ist es ganz alte, ganz furchtbare Zeug zum Teil. Was wir gar nicht anfassen wollen, dann muss man erst mal mit der Kettensäcke richtig aufräumen. Ein richtig aufgeräumter Code fehlt, dass man echt damit arbeiten kann. Weil im Moment, um sich frisch einzuarbeiten, braucht die man schon lange.
Was heißt lange in Zahlen?
1, 5 Jahre vielleicht, um zu verstehen, was da drin abgeht.
Also von außen zu sehen, man macht das nebenbei.
Ja klar, wenn man es nicht hauptberuflich macht, dann kann man sich das schon kurz mal aneignen, was da alles passiert.
Aber kurz ist dann immer noch ein Monat.
Kurz ist immer noch einiges.
Man muss sich ja auch nicht alles aneignen. Also es reicht ja auch, wenn man sich auf bestimmte Sachen stört. Da gibt es einerseits das Plug-in-System, was natürlich schon mal eine gut definierte Schnittstelle bietet, wo man halt gegen programmieren kann, wo man einfach funktionalisiert hinzufügen kann, ohne eben viel über das restliche Programm wissen zu müssen. Aber wenn ich das jetzt auch richtig, also beim GIMP Projekt bin ich ja außenstehend, so was ich dabei betrachte gerade ist, es gab halt eine Version 1.0, das war sozusagen das erste, was erstmal im Wesentlichen das tat, was man haben wollte und was überhaupt lief und nicht irgendwie die Develop Version war. So jetzt gibt es mit der Version 1.2 die nächste große Release, wo halt irgendwie neue Features dazugekommen ist, dass eine oder andere halt aufgeräumt ist, aber bei jeder Softwareentwicklung stellt man nach einer Weile immer fest, so jetzt haben wir zwar irgendwie das hinbekommen, was wir haben wollen, aber die Art und Weise, wie es funktioniert, ist nicht so, dass man jetzt problemlos alles das, was wir auch noch haben wollen, damit reinpacken kann. Also muss man irgendwie zum Riefreit zur nächsten Version schreiten. Das ist natürlich dann schon ein etwas aufwändigeres Modell.
Refactoring. Man macht einfach, man überarbeitet die ganze Software. Jetzt nehmen sie kleinen Schritten vor und sagt jetzt mach man das irgendwie, dann splittet man das vielleicht in zwei Unterverzeichnisse auf, wenn es vorher ein großes Unterverzeichnis war, Stück für Stück. Das ist immer so ein iterativer Prozess. Man schmeißt nie alles weg und fängt von null an, sondern man versucht immer möglichst viel von dem, was man schon hat und weiß, rüber zu retten.
Was du vorhin fragtest, was uns noch fehlt, was die Leute natürlich wirklich immer haben, weil es richtig professionelle Software ist. Die Leute wollen eigentlich schon gerne auch in ihrem Grafikstudio mit freier Software arbeiten, nur dass das halt wirklich noch ein Punkt ist, da fehlt es noch. Da braucht man das Farbmanagement, die Leute wollen von ihrem Auftraggeber, gesagt kriegen, da gibt es dieses Blaue und da gibt es eine Nummer in einem Penton-Katalog, das kann man nachschlagen und das hat Geflix so nachher auf dem Drucker auch rauszukommen. Und das ist ein Gebiet, was nicht ganz einfach ist, was auch mit Patenten durchsetzt ist, wo man also teilweise auch gar nicht so rankommt. Und wir haben uns halt letzten Sommer hier getroffen in Berlin, auch mit Entwicklern aus Amerika, hatten eine Konferenz so drei Tage lang und haben uns mal zusammengesetzt und haben uns entschlossen, wir machen ein richtig geiles GIMP 2.0. Und das machen wir quasi from scratch und das wird jetzt alles können.
Wie lange schätzt ihr, dass ihr dafür braucht?
Nächste Woche ist es fertig. Ach, das geht auch? Ja, das ist immer so. Also GIMP 1.2 war auch irgendwie nächste Woche immer fertig, ungefähr zwei Jahre lang.
Ach, das ist dasselbe wie mit meiner Diät, die fange ich morgen an.
Oder hier morgen höre ich zu rauchen.
Wann gibt es eine Declared Stable Version?
Das gehört mit zur Philosophie von Open Source. Es ist genau dann fertig, wenn es fertig ist. Und nicht wenn ein Marketing-Managentur sagt, irgendwie eine neue Version wäre angebracht. Sondern es ist einfach fertig, wenn es fertig ist.
Aber ihr habt euch nichts vorgenommen. Also ich meine, wenn ihr jetzt zehn Jahre dran umschreibt...
Nee, also schneller wie die jetzige. Also der Sprung von 1.0 auf 1.2, das ging ungefähr zwei Jahre, über zwei Jahre, zweieinhalb Jahre. Das war irgendwie eine Durststrecke unerträglich irgendwie. Und also bis 1.4 soll es im nächsten Jahr rauskommen, wenn wir uns da irgendwie jetzt nicht irgendwie vergreifen hier im Radio.
Hat ja keiner gehört. Gibt es noch irgendwie was Großes, an das ihr noch ran wollt? Also irgendwas, weiß ich nicht. Es gibt noch jede Menge Sachen, die vielleicht auch noch in Open Source hergestellt werden.
Die Weltherrschaft natürlich.
Die Weltherrschaft Open Source, das ist gut.
Also GIMP hat auch selbst schon eine ganze Menge losgetreten. Das Neue an GIMP war ja auch, dass es das erste Mal eine wirklich große Anwendung gab, die sozusagen den Namen Application auch verdient, was nicht nur so ein Kommando-Zeilen-Tool war oder so eine Server-Software, was bei Unix sehr verbreitet ist, sondern eben mit GUI, mit irgendwie Benutzerinteraktion, dass man interaktiv Content erzeugen kann, kreativ werden kann. Das ist natürlich eine ganz andere Sache, die von der Kultur her auch im Unix-Lager nicht so verbreitet ist. Das ist was Neues. Und jetzt erst mit den GUI-Systemen, die jetzt ganz gut funktionieren, und der Linux findet dann natürlich auch eine gewisse Beschleunigung. GIMP hat ganz erheblich zu dieser Beschleunigung beigetragen, weil natürlich viele Subsysteme, auf die man sich, wo man irgendwie bei Windows oder bei Mac OS, da hat man halt einfach schon mal ein sehr ausgereiftes, GUI-schwangeres Betriebssystem, wo man eben viele Dinge einfach schon mal hat. Und das gab es natürlich im Open Source Bereich zu dem Zeitpunkt, als GIMP gestartet wurde, 1995 war das ungefähr, gab es das halt, naja, kaum bis gar nicht. Und dass eben zwangsläufig musste sich GIMP alles selber erarbeiten und hat eben sozusagen einen Code produziert, der eigentlich gar nichts mit Bildverarbeitung zu tun hat, sondern eigentlich mehr erst mal das unterstützt hat, dass man das überhaupt tun kann, sodass sich jetzt daraus ein ganz anderes Projekt herausgeschält hat, was eigenständig ist, das heißt GNOME.
Erst mal GTK war es eben, was daraus entstanden ist. Und inzwischen gibt es dieses Projekt.
Was ist GTK?
GTK ist das GIMP Toolkit. Das heißt auch immer noch, dass GIMP Toolkit obwohl es inzwischen unabhängig entwickelt wird. Und das ist die Software, die es einem ermöglicht, auf dem Bildschirm Fenster darzustellen, Schaltflächen zu malen, da drin irgendwelche Bilder zu haben, mit dem Benutzer zu interagieren. Das was man halt einfach kennt, was so ein bunter Computerbildschirm hermacht, da sitzt irgendwo ein Toolkit, damit der Programmierer da nicht jede Linie einzeln ziehen muss, sondern sagen kann, ich will hier eine Schaltfläche und wenn man die drückt, dann will ich, dass irgendwas passiert.
Und das ist jetzt GNOME? Also das heißt jetzt GNOME?
Das heißt GTK irgendwie. Einfach nur diese Bibliotheke, die Buttons an Bildschirm zeichnet.
Und was ist dann GNOME?
Da haben die Leute das GTK hergenommen und haben drauf einen ganzen Desktop passiert. Sprich einen ganzen Satz von konsistent funktionierenden Applikationen mit einem Environment, so ein Toolbar, dieses Panel, was man halt auch von KDE und GNOME kennt. Wo man Applikationen starten kann, die alle etwa gleich aussehen. Das was man halt immer als Look and Feel bezeichnet, was halt möglichst konsistent sein muss einfach, damit man sich mit der blöden Kiste überhaupt irgendwie anständig unterhalten kann.
Das Ziel war halt wirklich, Linux vom Servermarkt, wo es sich halt schon verbreitete, auf den Desktop zu kriegen und auf dem User auf der Straße einfach was in die Hand zu geben, mit dem man einfach arbeiten kann. Nicht nur dem Hacker, der auf der Kommandozeile mit der Unix Toolbox irgendwie tolle Tricks vollführt, sondern eben auch was für den normalen User. Inklusiv der ganzen Anwendung. Es gibt inzwischen Super-Spreadsheets, also Tabellen-Kalkulationsprogramme, die mit einem Projekt entstanden sind und es füllt sich so langsam dieses komplette Office-Paket, was man eigentlich braucht.
Ich mach mal das Mikro von Mitch aus, dann kann er das Ding mal leiser zudrehen.
Catherine gibt es in allen Kompakten, wir sind sicher.
Es ist Chaosradio 57, wir reden über Open Source Development und ihr könnt mitreden.
0331 für Potsdam, 70, 97, 110.
Und falls Martin noch dran ist, dann kann er jetzt mitreden. Hallo Martin.
Martin?
Da ist einer dran, oder? Ich hab vergessen. Mitch, ja. Wenn du nochmal hier anrufst, hau ich dir auf die Finger. Nö, niemand auf dem Apparat. Ich kann nochmal die Nummer sagen lassen von dem freundlichen, jungen Herrn.
0331 für Potsdam, 7097110.
Wichtig.
Gut, dann läutet's wieder. Hallo, hier ist das Chaos Radio.
Wie jetzt?
Undemokratisch? Wir reden hier über Open Source Development und Sven sagt, ja meistens geht es relativ undemokratisch ab. Kinnas, was soll das? Kinnas, siehst du jetzt nicht dran, du antwortest jetzt.
Ja, ich meine einfach, es wird selten tatsächlich abgestimmt, so wie man das vielleicht aus dem Schulbuch als Demokratie bezeichnen würde, dass man bestimmte zählt, sondern es gibt halt Entscheidungen, die werden getroffen, indem man irgendwo versucht einen Konsens zu finden. Und der wird immer irgendwie gefunden. Und da haben ein paar Leute viel zu sagen, nämlich die Leute, die schon länger dabei sind, die viel dran gemacht haben. Und so gibt es halt irgendwo so eine gewisse Hackordnung in dem ganzen Leben.
Also das ist wie bei der Bundeswehr, da haben auch die, die am längsten da sind, am meisten zu sagen.
Ja, das ist so, es ist nicht automatisch, wenn du von einem anderen Open Source Projekt kommst, irgendwie und da mitmachen willst, ist nicht automatisch.
Ich denke auch, jedes Projekt hat so seine eigene Kultur, also bei Linux zum Beispiel, was ja auch immer so, wo immer das hohe Lied gesungen wird, der Netzdemokratie, ist halt auch so, dass da eigentlich gar nicht so viele Leute die Hand auf dem Körnern haben, da gibt es halt irgendwie Linus Torwalz, und der hat da irgendwie, fällt eine Menge Entscheidungen so, aber so ein Public-CVS dafür, wo andere einfach den Code mit einchecken können, den gibt es halt nicht. Während das irgendwie bei der BSD-Front irgendwie anders aussieht, da gibt es halt die Core Group von Developern, die ist auch sozusagen well defined, steht irgendwie schön auf den Webseiten, wer halt Core Group ist. Und man wird halt nicht so ohne weiteres Mitglied der Core Group. Und die bestimmt. Die bestimmt insofern, als dass sie natürlich irgendwie am meisten Plan hat, dass sie irgendwie auch alle fokussiert, solche Entscheidungen, und die müssen halt auch irgendwie gefällt werden. Aber man macht es halt nicht so mit Abstimmung, sondern man macht es eben mit der Hackordnung. Das ist eigentlich ein sehr schönes Wort im doppelten Wortsinne. Es gibt also durchaus auch in diesen chaotischen Tifusen gibt es durchaus irgendwie Ordnung, die dann halt im besten Fall kreativ ist, sodass ihr dann auch wirklich gute Ergebnisse erzielt.
Ja folgendes, ihr hattet gerade ein Programm vorgestellt, ich glaube GIMP, oder? Ja, ich arbeite eigentlich selber, mach selber Bildbearbeitung, beziehungsweise ich mache Pixel-Grafik. Sowas gibt es noch. Aber ich mach das und da ist jetzt die Frage, wie vergleichbar oder mit welchem Programm ist das vergleichbar? Ihr habt Photoshop genannt. Ich würde jetzt mal sagen, vielleicht kennt ihr es noch, ist es auch vergleichbar mit D-Paint? Also genauso gut. Ich meine jetzt nicht das alte D-Paint, sondern ich meine jetzt wirklich die letzte Version. Weil ich arbeite immer noch mit einer mega im Bildverhaltenen Programm, weil ich sage, ich habe nichts Vergleichbares auf dem PC gefunden.
Also die aktuelle Version kenne ich jetzt nicht.
Also es ist so, ich meine...
Du kannst halt bei D-Paint immer jeden Brush als Animation nehmen und mit allen Tools damit zeichnen. Im Part für die ganzen Zeichenwerkzeuge auch animierte Brushes, das geht.
Die neuen Brushes, die wir drin haben, sind glaube ich ziemlich genau das, was du in D-Paint hast. Was in D-Paint schon sehr früh drin war, dass du einen Stift hast, der eben nicht immer dieser eine Strich ist, sondern während du ihn bewegst, oder je nachdem auch wie du ihn bewegst, macht er andere Muster oder verändert sich in der Größe an der Farbe.
Aber ihr könnt ja auch zum Beispiel auch mit Brush meinetwegen, das ist ja bei D-Paint möglich in der letzten Version. Es ist mittlerweile auch möglich, eine Kamerafahrt zu machen. Das heißt, du nimmst ein Brush und du nimmst das Bild und du kannst das Bild eben vor- und zurückscrollen oder seitwärtsscrollen oder nach oben oder unten scrollen. Das sind zum Beispiel so die Eigenschaften, die ich eben am D-Paint wahnsinnig schätze. Oder du kannst eben einfach auf so kippen. Irgendwie gesagt, okay, ich will den jetzt räumen.
D-Paint geht eher so in die Richtung, dass alles irgendwie orthogonal angeordnet ist. Du kannst die ganzen Brushes und die ganzen Animations-Features mit jedem Werkzeug benutzen. Dafür fehlt halt dieser Berg von Plugins und...
Und Layereffekten und so weiter.
Und Layereffekte fehlt halt irgendwie. Es wäre schön, beides zu haben. So ein Brushsystem wie von D-Paint wäre natürlich für die ganz, ganz neue Version von GIMP 2.0 denn was irgendwann mal in 100 Jahren oder in 3 Jahren rauskommen soll.
Ich hab eigentlich was gefunden auf dem PC, wo ich sagen würde, ok, das plötzlich auf dem Amiga machen kann. Also da jetzt gerade im Animationsbereich, das hab ich auf meinem PC mit einem Programm bzw. mit zwei, weil ich brauch noch ein anderes Programm, um das GIF-Pinsel umzusetzen, hab ich einfach nicht gefunden, was so einfach ist.
Ich würde dir empfehlen, probier das mal aus. Auf jeden Fall, aber wenn du halt genau dieses eine D-Paint Feature so unheimlich liebst, gibt es eigentlich nur die Chance, dich hinzusetzen und uns zu beschreiben, wie das funktioniert, oder vielleicht sogar sich hinzusetzen und einen Patch zu schreiben, um ihn zu schicken.
Ich kann nicht programmieren. Ich bin Anwender, schlicht und ergreifend. Ich mach zwar auch Grafiken oder so, aber ich kann nicht programmieren. Das Einzige, was ich kann, ist HTML. Und da drin kann man keine Patches schreiben. Schlicht und ergreifend, dann müsste ich...
Beziehungsweise kriegt der Erste, der es schafft, einen Preis.
Also ich mein, Linux, OK, ich mein, gut, man könnte auch, was eben eine andere Überlegung wäre, man könnte euer Programm auf Amiga umsetzen, aber...
Ich mein, ist auf Amiga nicht einfach mit der neuen Version ESA eine POSIX-Leiter drin? Du könntest einfach probieren, das zu kompilieren auf Amiga? Müsste doch eigentlich gehen.
Es gibt Leute, die können das. Also ich kann es nicht. Ich bin jetzt auch aus der Szene seit einem Jahr draußen. Aber es gäbe Leute, die könnten das rein theoretisch auch kompilieren auf Amiga.
Es ist eigentlich schön, dass es auch wieder Amiga-Open Source-Szene gibt. Und ich könnte mir auch gut vorstellen, dass es nicht viel Aufwand wäre, GIMP auf Amiga zu kaufen.
Indie zumal ja auch Amiga und ich meine, das ist ein gutes System, es ist veraltet. Kann man sagen, was man will. Das Betriebssystem ist immer noch relativ gut. Ich sage mal so, die Amiga-Szene stört langsam. Das ist eben auch das Problem. Ich meine, ich bin einer der Unverbesserlichen, die sagen, okay, ich brauche diese eine Anwendung für Bildverarbeitung. Und genau deswegen habe ich es immer noch. Weil ich habe auf dem Windows Sachen, gut, Windows muss ich mal ganz ehrlich sagen, also Windows ist ein Betriebssystem, was mich überhaupt nicht überzeugt. Ich sage mal so, ein Betriebssystem, was mich in der Lage ist, wenn man eine Festplatte oder das Motherboard wechselt, dass man dann die Festplatte neu einrichten muss und was weiß ich alles machen soll. Wo man den Rechner auch noch runterfahren muss, um ihn auszuschalten. Das kann das bitte für mich ins Jahre 2001 sein. Du erinnst dich unserem hundertprozentigen Zuspruch, bei diesem Windows-Rand natürlich irgendetwas. Ich weiß und es gibt wahnsinnig viele Leute, die haben das beste Betriebssystem, was wir kennen.
Ja, was sie kennen, stimmt ja auch. Das ist das beste, was sie kennen.
Brauchst du ja fünf Tage, um es dann einzurichten. Das ist dann das große Argument. Ich arbeite bei einer großen Telekommunikationsfirma. Ich will keinen Namen nennen. Ich bin sehr erstaunt, mit was für einem System sie arbeiten. Um es mal so zu sagen. Das ist dann sehr lustig, wenn ich sehe, mit was für einem System sie arbeiten. Ich wollte eigentlich nur nachfragen, wie gut es ist. Oder ob ich sage, ich platze erstmal auf Mamiga. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, noch habe ich mir nicht durchgerungen. Um Unix auf meinem System, auf meinem PC zu installieren. Nein, der PC, den ich habe.
Das dürfte eine Qual sein, mit GIMP da zu arbeiten.
Das stimmt jetzt so.
Das ist eine Qual, mit GIMP da zu arbeiten.
Wenn ich mit GIMP angefangen habe, hatte ich auch bloß ein Pentium 90.
Angefangen habe.
Wenn man das Ding ständig neu kompilieren muss, sollte man schon etwas schneller rechnen.
Sonst ist es echt mühsam.
Sascha, danke für deinen Anruf. Wir müssen mal Nachrichten machen.
Okay, mach mal Nachrichten.
Schöne Nacht noch. Komm noch mal nach vorne, so lange machen wir eine kleine Muse.
Das's für heute.
Das Wetter nachts gebietsweise nebelörtlich glätte, das ganze um null Grad.
Die zuständigen Landesminister für Verbraucherschutz haben sich auf eine gemeinsame Linie bei der Rinderkrankheit BSE verständigt. Nach einer Sitzung in Bremen forderten die Minister die Bundesregierung auf, die BSE-Forschung zu verstärken und die Schnelltests auf alle Schlachttiere auszuweiten. Zudem sollten Medikamente und Antibiotika in der Tierzucht verboten werden. Palästinenser Präsident Arafat hat sich für eine Fortsetzung der Nord-Ost-Friedensgespräche ausgesprochen. Die Konfliktparteien müssten respektieren, was bei den Marathon-Verhandlungen im ägyptischen Tabe erreicht worden sei, sagte Arafat in einem Interview mit dem israelischen Fernsehen am Rande des Weltwirtschaftsforums in Davos. Israelis und Palästinenser sollten an den großen Erfolg des Abkommens von Oslo 1993 anknüpfen. UN-Generalsekretär Anan hat die restriktive Einwanderungspolitik der europäischen Regierungen kritisiert. Bei der internationalen Konferenz gegen Intoleranz in Stockholm forderte Anan am Abend die Staaten auf, den wirtschaftlichen und sozialen Wert von ethnischer Vielfalt zu erkennen. Angesichts der niedrigen Geburtenrate und der zunehmend älteren Bevölkerung braucht Europa mehr Zuwanderer, nicht weniger. Das UN-Kinderhilfswerk UNICEF will die erdgebenen Opfer in Indien mit mindestens 8 Millionen Dollar Soforthilfe unterstützen. Der größte Teil solle in Medikamente und Trinkwasser für die rund 100.000 Menschen in Not fließen, hieß es in New York am Sitz der Vereinten Nationen. Für das restliche Geld sollten Hilfsmittel für Familien und Schulen bereitgestellt werden. Aktuelle Verkehrsmeldungen haben wir zurzeit nicht, deswegen wünschen wir einfach nur gute Fahrt.
Danke, Falk. 0, 35 Uhr.
Krass präsentiert.
Jaha.
Die Tour zur Lesung.
Ja, das ist originell und auch so Schweinefröhlich.
Mit dem Autor. Mein Name ist Dietmar Wischmeier.
Und die Tour hat einen Namen.
Noch 20 Minuten, eine Viertelstunde Chaosradio 57 zu Open Source Development. Das ist ja alles ganz toll, haben wir jetzt gehört. Also Open Source ist super, Open Source herstellen ist ganz super. Nein, ich mein ihr müsst doch mit absurdesten Problemen kämpfen, oder? Weil das ist eine vergleichsweise unregulierte Welt und der Mensch will ja doch reguliert werden.
Ich hab gedacht, du möchtest noch reden.
Ja, ist klar. Also soll ich nochmal meine Schlaufe einstellen?
Ich hab noch keinen Schluck an der Warte.
Echt furchtbar. Nein, was für Probleme kämpft man da so?
Es läuft halt einfach auf mich. Und du denkst halt, du hast es fertig. Wir haben bestimmt ein Jahr lang gedacht, wir hätten es fertig. Wir können jetzt langsam mal sagen, dass es jetzt stabiler und damit könnte arbeiten. Und dann ist das ein Problem, dass man sich nicht halten kann, um weiter noch neue, geile Features einzubauen, die man doch bestimmt mal eben am einem Nachmittag da reinhaken kann.
Absolut sicher und so.
Passiert bestimmt nichts Böses und nachher hängt man dann einen Monat lang dran und versucht es dann doch noch irgendwie durch zu retten.
Wäre es manchmal sinnvoll oder wäre es manchmal praktisch, so was wie ein Druckmittel zu haben? So nach dem Motto, jetzt kommt mit dem Scheiß meine Gänge.
Ja, Druckmittel sind oft praktisch irgendwie, aber... Das soll ja auch noch Spaß machen. Also hier hab ich gerade gelesen auf Tims Aufstrieb von gestern Abend, steht ganz oben, es gibt keine EDV-Abteilung. Da steht also kein Projektleiter hinter dir oder irgendwie dein Chef. Oder sagt irgendwie, jetzt ist aber C-Bit in vier Wochen und wenn das bis da eigentlich läuft, dann ist die Kacke am dampfen.
Firmen pflegen auch in der Regel eine Art Coding-Style, wie in ihrer Firma durchzusetzen. Das heißt, wenn man als Programmierer da anfängt, dann hat man sich sozusagen an die Art und Weise, wie der Source Code aussieht, zu gewöhnen. So, da gibt es halt Reglementierungen, wie die Namen der Variablen und der Funktion benannt wird, wie man sie schreibt, ob man sie jetzt mit Unterstrichen trennt oder ob man sie irgendwie durch Wechsel von klein auf groß Buchstaben irgendwie voneinander unterscheidet und macht man das jetzt nur für Variablen, Namen und solche Sachen. Wo packt man einen Kommentar hin? Welche Kommentarzeichen benutzt man? Was kommentiert man? Wann kommentiert man? Kommentiert man immer oder manchmal? All diese Dinge, die sind in der Firma schon ein echtes Problem.
Die wird eingerückt.
Und ich meine bei Open Source, wie läuft das bei euch so in dem Bereich? Coding Style, ich meine mit Einrückungs-Sessions und so. Hab ich euch ja schon häufiger mehrere Stunden lang in den Bildschirmen gesehen. Was machst du denn da? Ich rück ein.
Halbe Stunde später, was machst du?
Ja, ich rück immer noch ein.
Naja, das ist halt auch so ein Problem. Der Source-Gut ist halt in fünf Jahren gewachsen und von verschiedenen Leuten geschrieben worden, die sich teilweise an überhaupt nichts gehalten haben. Haben das programmiert, wie sie wollten, wie sie es halt so schön fanden. Und da gibt es halt doch verschiedene Meinungen. Wie viele Spaces man irgendwelche Schleifen einzurücken hat, wo da die öffnende Klammer hinkommt und so weiter. Und wir machen eigentlich seit einem halben Jahr nichts anderes, als den Code neu einzurücken.
Und dabei irgendwie die eine oder andere sonstige Ekligkeit zu entfernen. Die eine oder andere sonstige Ekligkeit, die einem über den Weg kommt, hat halt gleich mit entfernt auf dem...
Ekligkeit, die einem über den Weg kommt? Ich programmier ja nicht. Also ich kann mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen, was an sowas eklig sein könnte.
Ja zum Beispiel gerade heute irgendwie, ich hab gedacht, mich trefft das Schlag. Ich hab tatsächlich, das muss man sich ja vorstellen, das GIMP Hauptverzeichnis sind 600 Dateien. Und es gibt halt irgendwie in dem ganzen Raum von Funktionen und Variablen, gibt es halt globale Variablen, die jeder kennt. Und da gab es doch tatsächlich eine globale Variable, die hieß TIMP unterstrich BUFF. Weil eine globale Variable und ich hab gedacht, mich trefft das Schlag. Das ist vollkommen unverständlicher Müll einfach.
Warum?
Weil, obwohl dieser Name so unaussprechlich ist, obwohl dieser Name so unaussprechlich ist, ist es halt ein Datentyp, den wir in GIMP dauernd brauchen. Das heißt, diese Variable wird überall verwendet. Und zwar immer als lokale Variable. Und kein Mensch hat mehr gewusst, dass irgendwo in einem Hedderfall für allefalls sichtbar eine globale Variable steht, die auch so heißt. Das war völlig unleserlich und es war unmöglich, das noch zu begreifen. Das ist so, wenn vor vier Jahren mal passiert, wird es einer extern deklariert und das liegt jetzt da rum und gilt in allen Funktionen. Du sagst irgendwann A ist 5 irgendwie und das gilt überall in allen Funktionen des A5.
Und was ist TimpBuff?
Das steht für Temporary Buffer. Ein kleiner Speicherbereich, in dem man vorübergehende Daten speichert. Wenn man das jetzt in einer lokalen Funktion tut, also eine kleine Routine, die häufig aufgerufen wird, dann ist das irgendwie so recht kein Problem. Aber wenn jetzt mehrere Funktionen global sich diese eine Variable, diesen einen temporären Buffer teilen, dann ist etwas unklar, zu welchem Zeitpunkt eigentlich dieser Wert was bedeutet und wer ihn gerade benutzt.
Jetzt habe ich es verstanden. Das ist so ähnlich wie bei Windows mit den DLLs.
Das ist ein... Ja, hat auch damit zu tun. Aber das ist das, was man auf jeden Fall eine Ekligkeit nennt. Das ist eigentlich sehr zurückhaltend formuliert.
Das ist mehr als noch eine Ekligkeit.
Aber wieso habt ihr es... wann habt ihr es gemerkt? Also es ist ja offensichtlich relativ lange unbemerkt geblieben.
Das hat auch nichts geschadet irgendwie. Das ist einfach widerwärtig irgendwie. Sowas macht man nicht irgendwie. Das ist unverständlich, unläserlich. Das geht einfach nicht.
Neulich im GIMP Workshop.
Das sind aber dann wirklich auch die Probleme, mit denen man sich dann auch mit seiner Community unterhält. Wie gehen wir da vor? Was tun wir jetzt sozusagen gegen TMP Buff? Da muss eine neue Variable her oder so, vielleicht die irgendwie einen sinnvollen Namen hat, der genau das beschreibt, was es tut. Aber wer weiß das schon so ganz genau vorher. Da muss man sich eben darauf einigen. Was benutzt ihr? Ihr benutzt IRC? Ihr benutzt Mailing-Disten?
Es gibt ein News Group, die allerdings von Usern hauptsächlich gebraucht werden, so untereinander Tipps auszutauschen und so. Aber da sind auch immer ein paar Developer, die da mitlesen. Die ist die internationale News Group ist in Comp, App, Graphics, GIMP. Parallel zu all den anderen Grafik-Gruppen, die da auch ihre News Groups haben.
Und wie viele Mailing-Listen gibt es?
Wir haben zwei Mailing-Listen, eine für User, eine für Entwickler. Und da spielt sich eigentlich alles ab. Und es gibt natürlich noch lokale Formen, User-Groups, die irgendwo sich zusammengeschlossen haben. Es gibt unheimlich viele GIMP-Webseiten. Es gibt eben nicht nur www.gimp.org, sondern es gibt unfällige Seiten, die Dokumentationen anbieten, einfach zeigen, was sie mit GIMP gemacht haben.
Plugins zum Beispiel.
Hacker, aber eben auch Künstler, die einfach zeigen hier, dass sie Bilder nicht gemacht haben. Es ist halt auch schon toll, was die Leute wirklich dann damit herzaubern.
Also wenn ihr mal sehen wollt, was man mit GIMP echt machen kann, dann geht mal zu tygert.gimp.org.
Also Tiger und NT.
Es sind schöne Bilder drauf, echt.
Dieser Tygert spielt eine besondere Rolle in der GIMP-Welt.
Das ist unser Power-User.
Er ist der Vorzeige-Power-User.
Also wirklich, wenn es um irgendeine Entscheidung geht, wie machen wir das jetzt? Machen wir das irgendwie auf der String, auf der Kontrolltaste oder auf der Shift-Taste? Damit Tygert gefragt und er arbeitet wirklich den ganzen Tag mit GIMP. Wenn man ihm zugut, ist es unglaublich. Der Tieffinger auf der Tessatur fliegt da drüber in der anderen Hand das Gratetablett.
Hier ist Chaosradio 57 und wir haben eine Menge Spaß, ich hoffe ihr habt es auch. Also wir lachen gerade über was, es ist ein Künstler aus England, der heißt Ali G, also Ali G, gebt einfach bei www.amazon.de, gibt es das auch als Import, Ali G ein und sucht danach und holt euch die DVD, das ist großartig.
Maximum Respekt.
Maximum, Treaty on Maximum Respect. Was machen wir eigentlich? Wir reden über Open Source Development.
Wir reden über Open Source Development.
Ali G zu reden.
GIMP Massive.
Solche Sachen müssen einfach mal frei ins Netz mit ohne Copyright drauf, es gibt so Künstler, die sind einfach so gut, die darf man niemandem vorenthalten.
Deine Festplatte ist gerade langsamer geworden, also das ist echt phenomenal.
Das ist eine Analog-Festplatte, das ist ganz neu.
Verblüffend, verblüffend, verblüffend. Das war's ja eigentlich fast schon, haben wir noch irgendwas vergessen?
Ja, natürlich, ich muss noch Hatjaha sagen. Was musst du noch sagen? Ich muss noch unbedingt Hatjaha erwähnen. Hatjaha Org. Also GIMP 1.2, die aktuelle Stable Release wird auch...
Hatjaha mit J oder mit Y?
H-A-D-J-A-H-A.
Alter, fatte, also so quasi Hatjach.
Ja, es ist irgendwie eine komische Sprache.
Da stecken doch die Araber drin.
Just mentioned Hatjaha Org. Na, jetzt kommt keine Antwort aus dem Internet. Es geht wieder stundenlang. Ihr zählt immer ewig.
Sehr, sehr unschön.
Das war's, was du noch sagen wolltest?
Also GIMP 1.2 ist the Hatjaha Release. Weißt du genau, was es ist irgendwie?
Ich dachte, du wolltest es jetzt hier lange Zeit im Radio auseinandernehmen. Ich erkenne mir das nicht, oder?
Nee, das ist irgendwie... Ihr werdet dahinter kommen.
Also hadjah.org.
hatjaha.org. Hatjaha. Nightvirtualm oder so ähnlich. Ja, es ist... Es ist alles ganz mysteriös.
Es ist auch wichtig, dass es alles ganz mysteriös ist.
Das eigentliche Geheimnis hinter Open Source haben wir natürlich nicht verraten.
Es gibt halt noch so etwas ganz Besonderes.
In diesem Sinne...
Das war Chaosradio 57, Open Source Development mit einem Studio von Mitch, Sven und Tim. Bis nächstes Mal wieder am letzten Montag im Monat. Februar. Wie viel ist das jetzt? Weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß nur, dass ich am nächsten Tag um halb fünf aufstehen muss.
Ohje.
Wir hatten Spaß. Ich hatte Spaß. Ich hoffe, ihr hattet Spaß. Morgen nicht. Ich hoffe, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ihr hattet auch Spaß. Hier gibt es gleich den Night Flight, und zwar ab 1 Uhr, mit Martin Böttcher. Und wenn wir Glück haben, geht die schöne Musik einfach nahtlos weiter.